I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING. I DIDN'T [__] DO ANYTHING.
THAT'S WHY I'M NOT CRYING AND SOBBING, [__] I DIDN'T
[__] DO ANYTHING, DUMBASS. YOU just want ME TO BE
GUILTY SO BAD. SHUT THE UP.
>> That is absolutely defamation and I will be suing you
for that. >> Now he's been made aware that there are like
real kids who were abused to make the things in that folder that
you leaked. Like there are It's a real
Yes, Lucari had a taxes folder situation. Lucari leaked some
on stream except it's
way worse than the Bosch stuff. When you when you go through
it, it's way way worse than the Bosch stuff. Learia Library.
This was my reaction as well. What the the like Yeah, Lucari
was absolutely like an avowed before this. Not super shocking,
right? Not super shocking he get caught out, BUT
BUT BUT IT'S A LOT worse than that. It's potentially a lot worse
than that.
I heard Lucari's VOD is 6 hours long. Is that true? I don't know.
So, let me walk you through his VODs. Okay. He starts streaming
last night.
He starts it up hour 35 VOD.
I believe that is where he leaks the material originally. Now,
just so we're clear, he didn't leak videos. He leaked links that
lead to videos. It's pretty bad. The stuff looks really bad.
Okay, what are we talking about? Is it a Vosch type situation?
It's worse than a Vosch type situation. Okay. Overall, Lucari
stream for like
6 and a half, eight hours, something like that. hour 35, 2 hour
29, 21,
and then 3 hours 40 about about 8 hours he streamed for. At the
end of an hour and 35, he leaks the the notepad that has the
material on it. Okay? And then
from from right there, let me tell you, from right when he leaks,
I think he's got a path forward to stay alive. All right? Unfortunately,
what he decided to do after leaking was delete his VOD, go live
again, and consistently get trolled and respond to chat. Okay,
the entire time he decided he was going to go live again,
get trolled by his chat repeatedly.
Okay, not a good idea, man. Not a good idea at all. All right,
very very very bad idea.
Okay. It just was never ever ever going to work,
man.
I don't know. I don't know what he was doing, dog.
It's It's some wild stuff. Okay. Okay. He was probably catfished.
He was not catfished. He was not catfished. Do you think Teone
will sweep for Lucari? No. Nobody will sweep for Lucari on this
one. Okay. So,
why don't I why don't I pull it up and then we can Well, can
I describe it to you first? what he leaked was a notepad. Okay,
a not the application, the Windows application notepad. Okay,
he pulled up a notepad and it had within it a file, a text file
that contained a link.
When you go to that link, when somebody were to n if somebody
were to navigate to that link,
they would be met with a list, I believe, of text files or possible
like links to websites that
Okay, there's other stuff in there, too. There's like stuff.
There's
uh there's all kinds of like
weird [__] in this, right? But most people are going
to see that there's there's a link that leads to and Lucari is
just done, right? Like that's all people will see
is confirmed, I believe. So, Reddit detectives, I I'm not going
to be the one to go check. And that could be something that would
have helped him had he not stayed live and been a complete. Okay?
Because he makes his situation so so so so much worse. Okay?
You have no idea how much worse he makes his situation by staying
live because what he does is he proceeds to go stay alive and
lie repeatedly about everything that happened. He just continue.
He just lies and lies and lies and lies. All right? He makes
up like what happened, how it got there. He blames a virus. Then
he blames like he deleted the file. It didn't realize he had
the file. Oh, then well I deleted that file. I I saw there's
bad [__] there. I went to it and I saw there was
bad THERE. WHY DID YOU SAY THAT? WHY THE [__] DID
YOU SAY THAT? Like I'm trying to be his lawyer, you know, mentally
in my head. He's like, I went there and I saw there was bad stuff
there and uh I I I deleted it right away. It's like, brother,
what the are you talking about? Excuse me. Are you good? Do you
understand what you're saying right now? Do you have any I So,
and it's hours of him trying to play video games and focus on
the video games and get tilted and respond to chat. Then he's
like, I'm not going to respond anymore. Whatever. I'll keep streaming.
It's fine.
And he's like in a battle of wills with his chat that he does
eventually lose. I've got all of the content from last night.
I've got all of it. Let me at >> dude. Wait, who got the
EDP edit? Oh,
There's no shot. He has the same
Oh, brother. Oh, brother. >> Wait till list of champions
that I like. >> No way. Okay.
You see this is we we probably won't watch the full thing, but
this eyebrow he pulls up he pulls up the notepad. Okay. And his
reaction to seeing what he pulled up on the notepad is just this
like eyebrow raise. I'll give him for that to be the only tweak
you have when you pull up that that notepad file on stream. That's
pretty good. But it is very funny that it's just a little eyebrow
flick up. Okay. Oh. Oh. Oh boy. Oh. Oh. Oh boy. Oh boy. >> What
was that? What was that? What was that? Huh? Huh? What? Um. Um.
Um. What was that?
What was that?
>> We Okay. So, couple important things here. Okay.
What he does is he pulls this not this notepad up. This notepad
is going to be where everything is. This is basically a link
to some, okay? Don't want to pull it up on your stream. You don't
want to do anything with it, but we know this is censored. He's
got two
tabs here. All couples something, which is the current tab he's
on, and then 500 JBT video fi.
So, right off the bat, what do we think JBT means?
let me give you a hint. First half of the word starts with somewhere
Lucari is soon to be.
that's that's 500
files very likely.
and
not I'm guessing it's another link to something like this. Now,
I'll be
I feel like I'm an internet DJ and this is a form of consumption
I've never considered, seen, heard talk of. I think that's good,
right? That I've never heard of people using like text like they
put stuff in text files. I think these are like password protected
text files like like raw roar text files that include links and
I'm like what? Who gets does somebody get this way? Who gets
this way?
What the the are we talking about? Isn't JBT the speaker brand?
Could be 500 songs. It is not, but I've heard that joke already.
Yes, JBL. It is not. This is like a level of gooning that he's
reached here. Yes. That is like unheard of. Hither too unre is
you're going to like find super niche
links to down to files that have passwords. You open the the
the file with the password, you get another link to something.
It's like links within links within links.
when you go to illegal websites, that's how you get those links.
Okay. I don't know that, man. Jesus.
It's some crazy stuff, though.
Oh, just closed my Twitch back end. All right. So,
now he has these two tabs up. Now, what's not shown in this video
is right after this, and I don't think I have an uncensored version
of this, okay? But after this leaks, Oh, wait. Maybe I can find
it. I can I got to be careful because I've got a video that includes
the link uncensored. Now,
you got to be careful with this uncensored link because explicitly
like I think there's there's a chance depending on where you
live that that's already breaking the law. If you were to have
this URL on your stream, you might already be breaking uh breaking
the law.
so hold on. I have I have like an uncensored version, but I'll
just show you what he does. Basically, he pulls this up because
he wants to talk about favorite champs or something. Okay. In
League of Legends. Let me see if I can find this. And then he
pulls it back on and he's closed these two tabs.
Sort of basically giving the game away that these two tabs are
bad. That if this was nothing, he wouldn't have closed this tab,
right? But he closes this tab, which sort of conclusively shows
us that this is the thing very likely. Okay.
Was
this the guy Pirate Software is being rude to about playing Warlock?
Yes. Yes. This is the guy. This is the guy.
do I even want to I That's enough of an explanation. I don't
think I have to show you. But basically, he pulls the notepad
off screen after this and then he closes those two tabs, pulls
it back on screen, and tries to keep talking. Okay. What's his
favorite champ? An I mean, Lucari is a degenerate. Lucari is
I already assumed Lucari was a pure
and possibly like a already. Let's look at this old clip with
with Sodapop in here. >> Your favorite >> for example.
>> My favorite waifu. Um
that's a good question.
>> Thoughts on Vahata?
>> I like Vaporeon.
Uh
>> Yeah. Well,
there's a different version of Vaporeon. That's uh >> Dance
on Aba.
>> Oh, you know what? Speaking of Pokemon, maybe it's Dawn.
I like Dawn a lot.
Dawn. Dawn. Pokemon.
Oh. Oh, it's like uh it's like this girl. I like Dawn a lot.
I like Dawn a lot. I like Dawn a lot. Uh canonically.
Canonically, I understand this is Japan. Canonically, can we
get an age on Dawn?
What What age is Dawn?
This does not look like a very old character.
We had a
Oh. Uh oh.
that's not good. That's
not good. That's not good at all.
>> You know, the girl from Pokemon, Dawn,
chat, don't worry. It's not like that. I mean, I just think,
you know, Don's cute, that's all.
>> oh, Soda had the same reaction I did. How old is Dawn
from Pokemon?
>> Wait a second. Listen, chill. Okay. >> Don is
a 10-year-old Pokemon trainer and former traveling compan.
>> I didn't want to say anything, but yet
it like that. If you want to talk about >> double digits,
proud of you, bud. Bro, listen. If you want to talk about waifu
waifu, if you want to talk about waifu waifu, we're talking right
now. >> Okay. So, Don is just the waifu, but because they're
10, they're not the waifu waifu.
>> No. Okay. When you mean waifu,
>> No. Say, say it. Don the 10-year-old is my wife. Say
that.
>> That's what you said. >> Ship it.
>> I'm never beating the allegations.
>> I I'll be back later. I got to I got to
>> All right. Yeah. Yeah, take take your guys home.
>> Finally, that guy left. >> I agree. >> Oh
my goodness.
>> He comes in talking that sort of weird
>> Okay, so that's that's an old clip of Lucari. All right,
that's an old clip.
Yes, this has been an in joke in in the OTK group with everybody
for a long time that Lucari likes this stuff. He's like an avowed
like an actual avowed and it's not even really been it's not
even been a like up for question.
He's just been an avowed in these circles. Everybody knows it.
It does seem weird that you know Mskiff goes in on Msk used to
go in on Teone and not this guy. I guess cuz this guy was like
somewhat popular.
Okay, he has like a bit of a meltdown on that. He deletes his
VOD. Okay,
deletes his VOD.
We get LSF threads spawning up almost immediately. Hold on. I
need I just have to be really careful here and make sure that
I'm not pulling up anything
that is going to be uh Hold on. Is this No, this is this is censored.
Okay, this is censored. I can I can pull this one up. So, this
was the one that got allowed to stay. There was a big fight on
LSF, actually, if you were awake when this happened. All right.
There was a big fight on LSF for about an hour where people were
posting about this and LSF kept deleting the threads. Now, I
think LSF is actually in the right here because people kept posting
the uncensored
links
over and over again. And I think LSF actually made the right
call here in deleting those cuz the this was like almost certainly
highly illegal to have anywhere. Like I know I I was watching
Chud while this was unfolding for a little bit and he was like
repeatedly deleting his VOD because he kept leaking um the URLs
on stream and he kept repeatedly deleting his VOD. Like he'd
go offline, delete his VOD, restart.
Here's another clip of Oh, I've got lots of clips of Lucari crashing
out. Okay, we've got all the clips here. Let me
Yeah, you're just going to keep Yeah.
Yeah. No, he had like a hundred of these. Just as a little preview,
we'll throw this in right now. Okay. HE HAD LIKE 100. >> JOKING
ABOUT IT. WHAT THE [__] WHAT? YOU'RE JUST WRITING
your own narrative. YOU'RE JUST WRITING YOUR OWN NARRATIVE, MAN.
What the else DO YOU WANT ME TO DO? WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
>> OH, I'M SO SORRY.
OH, I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
I DIDN'T do anything. THAT'S WHY I'M NOT CRYING AND SOBBING.
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING, DUMBASS. YOU JUST WANT ME TO BE GUILTY
SO BAD. SHUT THE UP.
Jesus Christ. I'm so sick of this.
You want me to be guilty? So,
>> no. So, I'm trying to walk you through the timeline
a little bit. Okay. So, he does the original leak and then he
goes live again and he's crashing out like a little bit. He's
got a guy, by the way, whoever this guy is, whoever the guy is
that comes in and like makes him crash out even further. Like,
it's like his buddy. Okay. He had like a buddy come in and with
him once he gets to his final VOD. All right. Somewhere around
here he deletes again. And then he's got a buddy who comes in
and messes with him. He's got He starts like googling like what
the laws are around Volvon and
it's rough, dude. Okay.
Yeah. No, I'm going to Yeah. Junarch, we're going to go over
all of it. Don't worry. We got all of it. We've got all the time
in the world.
Okay. Now,
here we're just we're priming context for who Lucari is and why
this is maybe a little less uh expected or a little less unexpected
than you'd think. Okay?
>> Like if you're if you're calm about like a counterargument
and you don't act like a like a like a piece of about it, like
typically I'm really chill with with counter arguments. If you
don't agree with something I said
and you're like
>> Nick or any reasonable person with a >> Now if
you're like me,
you feel uncomfortable with what's on your screen right now.
Lucari is having a totally separate discussion. He not even fazed.
This is the this is just a Tuesday for Lucari. Okay. For us this
is like oh this is really really weird. This is what the do you
put on your screen brother? for Lucari. He's just having a totally
separate conversation while this goes by. This is like not even
it's not even a little bit phasing for him. Okay. >> Yeah.
Go ahead, bro. >> And oh, he always has people spamming
images like this in his too. He's got like the most degenerate
goomer gooner stream. I remember when we were going through the
pirate software stuff, we would watch Lucari highlights and it
was like unwatchable because he just had all this crazy Gooner
going on all of the
Uh yeah, Maximus, I can't open I can't open the file names on
stream. I could like read them
here. I'll read because when you go through So again, if we go
through to the link here, there's like a list of file names.
Okay.
But if I open them, I can't put them on stream, but it's like
girls and animals
something 3D covers links inside
pure teens. And that's where we'll get into the real problem
here. Okay. One of the files is something about family news and
which you start to discover pretty quickly. And thank God for
Redditors. Redditors who are actual like avowed. Okay. Thank
God for these people.
It seems to me
that when you talk about this this new stuff, all right,
that's like a workaround to just talk about kids. Let me pull
this up on stream.
Here's here's a Reddit screenshot that I took. So that family
stuff which is in some of the file names when you go through
to the directory is 100%. It's a typical workaround predators
use to find it. That combined with JBT equating to this needs
to blow up. This cannot be ignored. So
that's the that's the scary thing here, okay?
you think about that. You like put it in your head and you think
about it. Now
what is C child abuse materials?
It's another way of saying child, but it's a little more I guess
academic.
Now, when you
dude, when you uh
all you have to do is think about it, right?
Like family,
if you're if you're looking for pictures,
what are you looking for, right? If you just wanted pictures
of
is family stuff legally considered No, I don't know. But there's
certainly a lot of other going on there. I don't know if it's
a loophole. Puppy wiggles. Is family stuff legally considered
though or is it a loophole? I assume there's some amount of loophole
there maybe in some places. How could we confirm this? Because
I ain't personally doing this research. Yeah. No, I dude
the furthest I went I was like really curious. So I opened up
like a fresh browser VPN up everything and I just like I just
clicked through to see like the the link, right?
And just to verify that those files were there, I'm not going
any deeper deeper into the files. I can't. I refuse. I just went
to make sure that like >> listen to to really try to cook
this guy, I was like I should make sure that those file that
he's not totally getting lied about.
>> And the um the like link that goes to the directory
of files,
that is true. That is real. Okay. um
had an ex's brother who went to jail for he had a lot of family
news him apparently they're naked. Okay, dude
Yeah, I didn't I didn't download anything here cuz I Listen,
I ain't on that I ain't on that life. I'm not going to jail.
Okay, but I figured I'll I'll I'll just make sure that it's not
going to be like he's not getting totally cooked. If this was
like an elaborate thing to to catch him, I I don't think so,
man.
Now,
here's here's the best case scenario for Lucari. Okay, the best
real case scenario here is that when you go to that link that
he like was looking for something that's on the line cuz he's
got a fetish and then he ended up going somewhere that included
stuff that's on the line like maybe his stuff or, you know, 18-year-old
stuff or whatever and he ended up here.
I think that excuse could have worked
before he did his entire meltdown stream.
I think if he had leaked this stuff and gone immediately offline,
gotten his [__] together, figured out some excuses
that made sense,
and then come back and explained it.
I think he could have been okay.
I've got the meltdown stream, Puffy Wiggles. Stick stick right
here. We're going to watch his entire meltdown from start to
finish. Okay, we're going to watch the whole thing. I've got,
you know, we got people
in high and low places who may or may not have already saved
his entire YouTube VOD.
The entire YouTube VOD and timestamped it. Okay.
There's We We've got a dedicated crew out here. All right.
No, we've got the whole thing. Puppy Wiggles, it's all here.
We've got it all. Don't worry. It's all archived.
I've got all of his VODs. I've got everything. Isn't it toss
to show his stream after a ban?
I think it would be to show the toos stuff, but I'm not going
to show the to stuff. No, no, no. You can cover No, no, no. It's
not to anymore. It used to be to show ban streamers content,
but it is not anymore. Chudlogic just dropped a crazy take. I
happen to be searching for a post I made in his Discord and I
just saw his latest take. Hold on. Latest update from Chudlo
Logic in his view. But they'll just $5
is going to make me have to reach out to the Mounties to Oh my
god. You have friends who saved and time stamped the
Uh yeah, but this is just his meltdown content. Not when he had
the actual stream there. Or not when he had the actual link on
stream.
But yes. Yes.
What voice is that? Hold on. What voice is that? Give me a second.
You've ever watched a cartoon? You are a bad
Okay, this is the new bar. This is our new bar, guys. If you've
ever watched a cartoon, you are a bad apparent that's just that
voice was Indian in Kickbot. Okay, I kind of kind of [__]
up, but apparently that voice is just called Indian. Jesus.
Okay, we are going to keep going. Oh, I forgot to say a basket
lotion. Thank you for the primer. Appreciate it, guys. If you
got primers on Twitch, throw your primers in the pile, okay?
Appreciate it.
All right. What What are we going to next? I'm just going to
cover a little bit of this stuff from the early reactions. All
right.
This was from his first stream when he immediately came back.
All right.
Quick donation.
>> Checked out that link you sent me. You said it was some
good New York pizza spots, but these file names, >> that's
what I thought. >> Kind of weird, you know. >> Much
love from the PCU,
That's That's like a preview of what's to come is just him memeing
through getting called a PDF by his chat over and over again
and he just keeps trying to meme through it. Okay, what's funny
is he looks exactly like the person to have those fetishes. Bro
said he doesn't own those links so it's okay.
Has anyone done worse acting? It's pretty rough, man. It's pretty
rough when he first comes back. Okay,
Miskf came along, decided to check some of this stuff out. All
right. Now, oh, no limiter got rid of Oh, did Miskf show the
links? Msk might have shown the links. Oh,
well. Oh, did No limiter get rid of all of his Miskf stuff?
Oh, all of this is gone. Oh, that's too bad. There's a lot of
Miskf reactions to this. Okay,
hold on, hold on, hold on. I think it's at the top of LSF. Let's
just check it out. >> I'm pretty sure. >> Oh, you
are head top. >> If I go If I go find Oh god. Oh god. There's
a lot of
There's a lot more Lucari stuff. Oh no. Here's the here's the
clip. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Hold on. Let me >> again. I need to check this off
stream. >> Just tipped $5.
>> I just got a tip about something involving my friend
Lari. That folder was actually just a misspelled folder of photos
of me. JPT.
>> Okay. Thank you very much. Thank you very much,
Justin Trudeau. Appreciate it. Linked to me. You did. >> Okay.
Nice.
That is absolutely defamation and I will be suing you for that.
>> The ghost put those. Okay. First off, you're
a thous.
>> That's not a ser That's not a serious >> Just
call me a If you don't think I'm suing you, Lucari, for everything
you just have, you're out of your mind. That's insane what you
just said.
>> That is crazy. I don't >> You just call me a >> Miss
sees Lucari's a huge life raft. He does. He does. Uh there's
a YouTube vid where Lucari's asked if he liked lollies during
a lie detector test and he said yes he did. Yeah, I have no doubt
about that. M is just Yeah, I have no doubt Miz is trolling there.
Okay, but Miz is jumping on this as a huge life raft. Where's
Where's M's reaction? Somebody find me Miz's reaction to Dude,
find me Miz's reaction
to the Asminol bit. Okay, cuz we have we have a moment here where
Lucari
says, "Oh, Asmin Gold Asmin Gold sent me a message." He's letting
me know that, you know, I should get a different computer for
that. Do we have that deleted
or is that here somewhere? Hold on. Is that deleted or is it
here somewhere? Nope. Not these ones.
Yeah, right here. This is the This is the Asmin gold message.
Okay. me said, "Bro, you need a Asmin messaged me said, "Bro,
you need a separate PC for that stuff." Oh my god,
>> dude. Now, I believe they just finished recording a
podcast
and Asmin Gold, you know, Asmin Gold clarified later today. >> He
doesn't know what that about. He doesn't He has got no idea.
Okay,
now let's let's just check this real quick. I should I should
grab the Asmin stuff real quick here. So, Asmin put this tweet
out, I think this morning when as soon as Lucari said this. Yeah,
this morning. Info had just come out and the clip I saw had the
names and everything censored. Obviously, I wouldn't have said
this if I knew what the content was.
Oh boy. Oh boy.
That's That's not good for Lucari, by the way. That's everybody
That's everybody scattering to the wind. That's everybody going,
"Good luck, Lucari. You got this, buddy. I believe in you, Lucari.
You got this, brother." They're like also looting from a thousand
miles away. You got this, buddy. Good luck. I know we were friends,
but good luck.
Oh, Really had a response. Twin
>> You openly admitted you ever do research or read articles
outside of Twitter. How can you shamelessly tell others to read
I don't need to understand whatever article you want me to read.
All I need to understand is human psychology and incentives.
and incentives and human psychology are the deciding factors
of how people will behave. Uh I don't need to read your little
your little special book or your Wikipedia article or anything
else besides that. None of that stuff matters. What ma what
what matters fundamentally is how do people act, how do people
think and how do people respond to incentives. If you can understand
that then nothing else
It's pretty simple.
I don't
I don't understand. Wait, why is that relevant to this?
I'm I'm a little confused about how why that's relative to this.
That That's That's cringe.
It's very cringe. Asmin Gold is very cringe sometimes. Okay,
hold on. This is the This is the Mizkiff reacting to Asmin Gold's
message.
Dude, Miz just straight up I I appreciate Miz going hard as a
drama streamer. Miz straight up camped Lucari for like 8 hours.
Miz literally was like, "Okay, this guy." Miz feels like he was
backstabbed by Lucari, right? Miz leaks a bunch of stuff about
Lucari, by the way. Bunch of stuff about Lucari, if you guys
don't remember. Okay. Uh
uh what's How do you spell this name?
This Cuckoo girl was Lucari's like girlfriend. Okay.
Jesus. Is this I don't know if I could I was just about to pull
up a picture of her and I don't know if I could pull that up.
Jesus Christ.
There we go. That's her Twitch banner. Okay. I can't get banned
for pulling up her Twitch banner, right? There's just no way.
There's simply no possible way. This is Cuo. This is Lucari's
ex-girlfriend. Now, she accused Msk
of
more or less outright rape, right? That she was like too drunk.
she was blackout drunk and that Miskf assaulted her. And I think
Lucari basically didn't come out and say anything different.
I see why they broke up now. Yeah, this is way way too Listen,
this is at least
at least 25 years too old for Lucari. Okay. At least 25 years
too old for Lucari. I think she's like 33 34. At least 20 25
years too old for Lucari. So, I think I think that Msk feels
like Lucari betrayed him. And so, Msk went and did literally
like
eight full hours of Lucari content. Lucari leaked his and Misk
was like, "Okay, I'm watching this guy's stream until he goes
offline." He just watched the entire stream.
And I appreciate that level of hate. Okay, that's that's very
cool. Misk is actually on some Demon Time now. I do love to see
it. All right. And he leaked some stuff. I will started reacting
at 5:13. Well, I'm not going to watch Miz start the start of
Miz's reaction, Jakun Arc, because I know for a fact that Mskiff
doesn't give a about leaking any of those links and that he still
hasn't deleted his VOD, so he just doesn't give a [__]
All right. All right. Anyway, now
as far as right now goes, Lucari has been banned. Okay. Lucari
has been banned from Twitch and Kick.
So, as of two hours ago, I believe that's where he got everything
ended. Okay. So, it looks like streamer ban says it's a
1, three, seven, or 14-day ban. They don't know yet. It's temporary
ban. So, he is banned from Twitch.
And he just got banned from Kick like right before we went live.
So, Twitch and Kick both have banned Lucari.
All right. We They've both banned
All right.
Now,
from here,
I do believe we can get right into his stream when he finally
comes back. Okay.
A round where he comes back. Okay. There's a round where he comes
back. 5 hours, 24 minutes, 25 seconds. Bunch of people spamming
diddy a whole bunch of funny stuff about Lucari. Okay. In the
chat. Okay. I think we start getting time stamps around here.
This is where we get to the like uh the harder defense stuff
here. Okay, we'll be around where he's playing Starcraft. I just
want to make sure I get everything from in between. Okay, I think
before this in the VOD, if I remember correctly, he gets this
call from a friend. Okay, this is the big call from a friend
>> that we don't want to miss. All right,
>> his buddy comes in
and actually starts questioning him why he is still live. All
right. At this point, you know, he's leaked some weird files.
He didn't have to still be live. He could have gone
Dude, I also I was like going to bed, so I only fired off one
tweet. I should have fired off a bunch of tweets. This is my
first tweet, dude. When he first comes back, all right, in his
here, I I'll pull this VOD up so you can just watch. He like
knows he up and he's like not really laughing about it or or
or
anything when he first comes back. He's sort of just like silently
sitting here. It's honestly sucks, man. I like Lucari. He's completely
cooked. There are 100% people reporting him and he will get a
visit. He'll definitely get a visit. Now, there is some like
plausible deniability here. There's like a possibility that he
could have some excuse for like how he got there. The issue for
me is once he starts trying to explain during the stream how
he got there, what happened, why it happened, it makes no sense.
He lies multiple times. I haven't gone through like the later
parts of the stream, but I was watching. The first excuse he
comes up with was well guys, like when I first saw what this
link was, I deleted it, but it was still in my notepad. And it's
like, okay, I don't know for sure. Somebody could test this right
now. Go make a text file, open it with notepad, edit it, and
then go to your like file explorer and delete it and see if it
stays in the notepad. What used to happen in Windows and I don't
know if it happens in Windows 11 now was Quinn already tested
this. Okay, perfect. Junarch, how did that go? Cuz I feel like
it it used to tell you the file is in use. You can't delete it
right now.
Okay, hold on. Somebody find me this Quinn clip right now of
Quinn testing it. That Yeah, that's been proven to be a lie.
Dude, I was sitting in a in a grip chat while this was happening
and I'm like, dude, why would you say that? That's obviously
not how Windows has ever worked. Like that was the dumbest lie
I've ever heard in my entire life. Notes persevere in notepad.
Okay, hold on. Somebody find the queen clip, >> Dude, just
look at the chat. Black hashin.
Dude,
>> that [__] bro. I'm going to be honest.
>> Those aren't my links.
>> Those aren't his links, guys. Those aren't links. >> Own
the links or something. I don't own those links, bro. >> He
doesn't own the links.
You're even on the link though, bro.
WHAT? I DIDN'T SAVE ANYTHING.
That's what I'm telling you. I didn't save anything, dude. >> What
a strange.
>> What the does that even mean? Okay, just cuz we've got
a couple more people filtering in. I'll go through the original
thing real quick again for you guys. Just we have a lot more
people filtering in and I'll just I'll show you one more time
right off the bat. Okay, so I believe this is censored. We'll
pull this up. Pop up. Pop up, please. Jesus,
Laggy is [__] over here.
Yes, this is the sensor version. Sorry, I just got to make sure.
Okay, so Lucari was streaming earlier. >> Champions that
I like
>> and he leaks this. Okay, he leaks this notepad with
a link. This link goes to severely significantly
worse content that you than anybody would ever claim to have
watched. Okay. This link goes to a site that's got more links,
more redirects or files. I believe that goes to things likely
uh what else?
Stuff. It's like it's a lot of very very bad. Okay. Very bad
[__] All right, this is Quinn. All right, perfect.
Perfect. Perfect.
Now, within that, yeah, there's a whole bunch of bad. Not only
that, but there is a second tab here that says 500 JBT video
file blah blah blah blah blah. Okay, this is very likely. And
if somebody were going through all of this, I would expect that
somewhere in that list of really bad videos that are on that
other site, I'm guessing you could probably cook them. If you
can find this this file name, the 500 JBT video file thing, you
can find this file name. I think this is likely that he went
to this link,
right? And this is what I was thinking about doing, but I thought
better of it. Okay,
so this is like a text link and then this right here is going
to if that file name is in this list is in the list that's censored
then I think he's cooked that he literally downloaded another
file from that site and he is okay.
Yeah, I don't I'm not doing that detective work. Okay,
so it's just a little too dicey. But that's what he linked was
basically he he leaked that he had this file on his computer
that contained a link to a site that had all kinds of horrific
[__] on it. Okay. Yeah. Um I think he did have to
save it. Well, he saved No, he saved this file. He's full of
if he says he didn't save this file. He absolutely saved this
file. It downloaded. He in fact later he says he downloaded it
like it downloaded automatically which by the way is another
switch up. Okay. But that is what originally happened here. Okay.
One file had 6,000 gigabytes. Damn. 6 terabytes of data. All
the weirdest, grossest porn you could imagine. Okay.
All right. So, that's that's catching you up a little bit on
what Lucari was up to. And we're just watching him cope through
this. So, he just said, "I didn't download anything. I don't
have the links. Those links aren't mine." >> Oh, wow. I
must make sure it stays that >> Okay, that's it for this
little bit. Now, there are a couple little humps over here, but
there's another big moment coming up right here. And let me just
throw this Quinn clip up because Quinn's gonna test Quinn's going
to test some of the Lucari stuff. Okay.
dog deck porn.exe
video saved. I don't even know yet to save. CL.
There it is.
>> So, multiple tabs. >> I think again on Lari's
side, I do believe he's arguing that he went to some website.
He didn't initiate a download. It just auto downloaded this file
with like this this text file and he opened it to see what it
was. Okay,
now that's a little believable
if he only had one tab. Okay, he's getting brutally destroyed
by his own lies because he had more than one tab. Okay,
fool me once, shame on you. Fool me twice, shame on me. Okay,
these are these are the two tabs in question.
So, if it's a if it's an auto download and he just opened it
and he didn't actually he didn't actually want to go to any of
it. Why has he got another one? Why is there a second one there?
Oh, hold on. I I think guys, in my opinion, this is a text file
that downloaded to his machine and he opened. That's what I think.
I don't think he wrote a notepad. People are are suggesting he
like wrote a unique notepad. I don't think so. I think it's far
more likely that he opened this file,
right? That he had he download this file downloaded from somewhere.
He either did it intentionally or unintentionally and then he
opened the file anyway.
But two tabs, you you don't fool me anymore. Okay. Can't get
caught again.
>> I need to move back.
>> X skates are up.
An enemy has been
>> apparently another moment here. I don't know if it's
leaked content or what
>> I remember when she sewed my dress with >> An
enemy has >> his chat is cloth. >> An enemy has >> his
chat is going off on this stuff the whole time. >> Has
been slain.
>> This guy's sting. >> An ally has been slain. >> This
could just be leak stuff. I don't know. I'm going through. By
the way, this is before. This is his second VOD after it leaks.
And basically, he deletes his VOD somewhere coming up
>> Come on. Show me. Show me another pop
>> I'm just making sure we get everything, guys. Okay.
>> The sweeten
with me.
>> There really no popup here. >> Oh, rated. If you
want to elsa frogs.
>> if you're not really toxic at us.
>> But it's going to be hard for you to be more toxic than
my job.
>> Is that all we get here? >> That might be all
we get here, >> dude. Holy.
That's all we get here. Okay. >> They're saying I should
play Prison
Can we play Prison Sim? Like actually play Prison Simulator?
Hold on.
>> I mean, might as well.
>> Might as well.
>> I mean, that would be variety.
>> After this, we're going to the clip with his buddy.
Okay. Cuz it's also in the spot. I just don't know if we missed
it or what.
>> It's not really taking this so seriously. You should
take this a little more seriously, Lucari. It says in the description
that you're a guard. So, I don't know if this is accurate.
>> Um, we showed the Asmin message already or we showed
that that clip already. Junarch the the Asmin clip.
>> Oh, it says you're a prison guard.
Game is I played it. >> No worries, man.
Make sure we get We got to get everything. Okay. We got to get
everything in here.
And again, a lot of this will be dead air as he's contemplating.
Oh, we're not even into we're not even into the meltdown stream
yet. Trucker Joe because I think what happens here is at some
point he's going to end this VOD. He's going to go live again
and that's when he really starts melting down. He starts playing
games by himself and he really starts melting down. Okay. He
had a 2 and 1 half hour stream after the initial leak that went
kind of okay that he was just memeing and and like he still had
his friends playing with him and then I don't know if his friends
kind of like said explicitly, "Hey guys, we're um hey Lucari.
Uh I'm not gonna be on stream for this. Okay, I can't do it.
I don't I don't know if they did that or what, but he ends up
playing Starcraft campaign mode by himself and like seething.
He's just staring off into the distance right now. I'm skipping
forward, by the way. I'm skipping forward like 10 seconds at
a time and he's just sitting here like staring at something off
screen. I don't know if this is Discord or what's going on here,
but the 10-second skip, he's still looking. 10second skip, he's
still looking. 10sec skip, he's still looking. So 40 seconds
of like looking off to that side monitor just trying to figure
out what's going on trying to calculate trying to figure out
chat. No, I think chat is over here.
I think he's very often looking over here at his chat.
this other side is like a second monitor with other
dude has a lot of emu alerts. He's People are spamming Emiru
to give him strength and
it's not helping. >> It's EDP445.
Prison Escape Simulator. Dude, who is
I don't know, man.
I don't know. If you don't know who he is, where'd you get those
glasses, bro? Where' you Where'd you get those sunnies from,
dog? Where those come from? Why you got the same sunglasses ED
as EDP? What's going on here?
This is a black dog whistle right here. I think if you got these
if you're black, you got these sunglasses. You need those in
the those need to go in the trash immediately. Okay.
That's uh that's [__] up. They're spamming emery
cuz Miz was watching the stream. Miz was watching the stream
like the whole time.
Yeah. Okay.
All right. This is very near the end. I do want to just go to
the end and see why he
he does shut his stream off here right at the end.
uh category. >> Does he say anything or does he just end
and then come back? Yo, what goal
and your freedom? Oh, maybe.
Wait, did that go back to back to back? Oh, and then he a 21
minute one. Okay, so he's got another stream right here and then
he's got this uh this longer stream right after this. Okay. All
right.
Now, I think the next thing we want to watch is his conversation
with his buddy. Okay.
Yes. This is the one. This is the one we want to watch cuz I
believe this is from the first stream and then we're going to
get into the longer meltdown stream. All right.
>> Uh, first of all, you're a
>> What the
>> Oh, no. This is this is in the meltdown stream. This
is when he first fires up Starcraft. Aha. >> I I just want
to ask you one thing. >> What's up? >> Did you know
that was in that links in those links? Okay. Do you know?
>> Listen, man. I >> So, how did you get those links?
because I download a lot.
>> I I understand how the kundra friends works. You realize
But you realize that like half of the streaming world right now
thinks you're right. >> Yeah, but I mean it doesn't matter.
They're always going to think that. Like there's nothing I can
say or do that'll change. There's one thing
>> wait that is so there's an element of truth to that
that like basically everybody already thought Lucari was a but
there's a big difference between and we don't want to acknowledge
it most of the time but there is a big
difference
in like between oh this guy is really inappropriate with like
anime characters and like all this versus this guy's straight
up looking at like real images of kids
that that's there's miles people say they're the same thing until
you actually have to make a differentiation between the two.
Right now there's yeah evidence of not just animation but
right and there's there's just miles and miles and miles of distance
between these two >> slowly and then the other thing is
real children getting those are two different >> Yeah,
I know bro. >> The second thing >> Yeah, I know bro
like what
are you good? >> Yeah. Oh, you like disprove that because
if if you think it's a joke, which I mean I I still believe you.
That's why I'm calling you. I don't think you're a necessarily,
but you >> Oh, NO.
THAT'S SO [__] UP. That's so [__] up
a caveat to throw in here. If you're going to call this guy in
his worst possible moment, I don't even think you'll
necessarily,
dude. Is this poff or something? This is some Balkans guy. This
is some Balkans [__] I don't think you're necessarily,
but >> necessarily. you realize that the longer this drags
on, the more you you they will view you as a actual
>> Oh, this is the other thing was him staying live and
having like these meltdowns and saying just being like a total
This gives people so much ammunition to use against him. It's
so
stupid, man. It was so dumb for him to stay live through all
of this. Okay,
I truly believe and I said this right off the bat, everybody
already thought Lucari was weird as
right. If he just logged off, if he just logged off instantly
when he leaked that, seen what it was, logged off, gotten together
with a couple friends, been like, "Hey guys, we need to come
up with the story that works, okay? not lied eight different
times about what was happening or what he was doing,
not told like eight different contradicting stories. I think
he could have come out of this.
But brother, you stayed live and you just kept saying weird.
You kept like contradicting yourself over and over
Oh man, it's
>> rough, dude. Okay. jailbaked
family
like 3D real children getting abused. >> You realize that,
right? >> And this also him cuz now he's no longer ignorant.
Before he could have pled ignorance, right, and not responded
because of pleading ignorance. He could have said, "Oh, I I logged
off cuz I leaked some embarrassing and I didn't know what it
was and I blah blah blah blah blah." He could have come up with
some story. HE COULD HAVE COME up with anything. But now he's
been made aware that there are like real kids who are abused
to make the things in that folder that you leaked. Like there
are it's a real problem. >> Getting sexually abused. You
realize that, right?
>> Oh, hold on. Let's get that in. >> Those links
were jailbait
real children getting sexually abused. You realize that, right?
>> Yeah, I know, dude. That's why I
That's why I didn't download anything like chill. Okay. >> I
mean, I I I trust you, but I I'm really just about the perception
of it because I was also abused as a minor. So, I really just
want to know how
>> what why why did he throw that? Why did we get that
nugget in? I I don't even know who that GUY IS. WHY WHY DO YOU
INCLUDE THAT PART >> ANYMORE, GUYS? cuz he
>> Wait, does Lucari kick him off at that point? That would
be very funny. I was also abused as a child. Uh, disconnect from
the call. Dude, get the out of here, man. Don't virtue signal
in my [__]
Okay, as right as he opened up Starcraft. So, here's where he
opens
He closes. He goes to Starcraft. He starts opening it. It's got
to be somewhere around here, right where this guy comes in. How
far were we into Starcraft here? Oh, he had he had the Starcraft
menu open. Okay, hold on. He had Starcraft open. He was sitting
at the menu here for a second. Right here.
>> Oh, it must be between missions or >> Hybrid production
lab. I will not let this continue. >> We will go to Revengard
and destroy
their defenses. >> The asteroid field is highly volatile
and guards the base's outer rim. The >> Hold on. Do I have
a transcript on this
I don't have a I don't have a transcript on this yet. We have
time stamps from 3 hours onward. I just don't know if he maybe
doesn't get into it too much. Carriers could strike at the facility.
We will set a course at once. Aman has taken away my armies.
>> Check with Chud for the time stamps. I can't check with
Chud for the time stamps. I don't think Chud has the time stamps.
He just covered this live, right? He was just watching this live.
I don't think he has timestamps written down. I have a bunch
of timestamps for this. They're just from like 3 hours
>> So, shall I take away his? you though. Okay, I want
you to open up a notepad. I want you to open up notepad, write
something in it, then delete the file, and then see and open
up notepad again and see what happens. Okay, there we go.
All right. Now,
how much do we want to splunk around this VOD? How much do we
want to splunk around this VOD? That's what I'm That's what I'm
wondering. He does, but Okay. Okay. Hold on. >> They want
your all stuff. Yeah, bro. They have like zero context and like
no matter what you say, they're
they're going to trash you. I don't think one exists yet, low
tech. But I'll be honest, I'm starting to figure that's where
we go. Okay,
I think this is what we're going to do. >> You just sue
Microsoft?
Honestly, I should actually.
>> So, what is this? It's like a notepad glitch. There's
like some notepad glitch that he got caught by. >> It brings
me great joy that the purifiers have chosen to join the Dealon,
but Aman's armies are still a >> Are away from you. As
ordered my dark >> bases could strike. The spear of adune
will not be saved. No, I didn't. >> However, our car >> so
there you go. >> The spear of adoom will not be saved.
No, I didn't. >> However, our carriers could strike the
whole facility.
>> I think he's given it away. And I do think this is the
case that he downloaded the file, right? He downloaded the file.
Quinn debunked the glitch. So, let's watch let's watch Quinn
debunking whatever this is. Okay.
and that on Windows 11 text docs aren't correctly removed.
>> Oh, but this did just get updated. >> Hold on.
This was a thing that used to happen. If Quinn's fully up to
date, then this won't happen to him. Here, I'm hitting play on
this. One sec.
>> Did he save? I don't even know yet to
there it is. Now I have I need to have multiple tabs up, right?
so now I'm going to delete test.txt.
So I'm on the latest update. Let me just check I'm on the latest
update. I'm on the latest
I'm on the latest Windows update. Check
All right,
man. He needs Notepad++.
What is he up to, bro? Oh, wait. I got another one.
It's a male. Oh, wait. It's just a It's antivirus. No, we're
good. We're good. I want the latest version. Okay. So, there
we go.
Delete. Okay. Okay. No, it's not there. I mean, I'm going to
be honest.
Now, hold on.
Do we have the claim from Lucari?
Somebody find me the precise claims from Lucari cuz I think he
makes multiple claims here. Okay. He makes multiple claims and
I don't know if he's even claiming that he closed Notepad. I
know I often don't close Notepad. I just leave it open perpetually,
right?
And I don't think that I don't think
that it's likely that this was deleted or that like um it was
something he entered himself,
right? Like it's it's something he just opened.
Uh, I just did that and my notepad kept the info in the notepad
even with the file gone. Okay, Arurus, the question I should
ask is does it show is not saved? You know how in Notepad you
get basically when you have something that's unsaved, you get
this like little dot. Okay, so before he does text.txt,
you see how how you get this little dot here? That's what you
have before you save, right? You have this little dot. I don't
see that little dot in the tabs,
right? There's no little dot here.
So, I don't know. I don't think that he necessarily edited this.
>> Train just tipped $5 window 11 doing more to expose
pedo than our current
>> Absolutely true. Yes.
Thank God for Bill Gates.
All right, we go back to this. >> We will set a course
at once. Aman has taken away my armies. So shall I take away
his. >> You did though. Okay, I want you to open up a notepad.
I want you to open up notepad. Write something in it. Hold on.
>> Delete the file and then see what and open up Notepad
again and see what
>> Oh, well that's what he asked for. Oh, Quinn did exactly
that. Oh, Quinn did exactly that. This is the This is the problem.
This is why Oh, brother.
>> What is he doing
that this is why he's going to get totally on this is because
he is quite literally
himself later with all of the lies. Okay, he is himself with
the lies. What was his excuse? Well, he's saying that basically
he deleted the file before he opened Notepad, but that's not
what happened. It's obviously not what happened. He's just lying
there. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, it'll stay there apparently even if you
delete the file. Okay. I believe that
now. I I could believe that. Now, I think what happens later
is he reopens the notepad and goes to it and the file is still
there. By the way, I do believe
It does have the unsaved dot on it. Oh,
That's very interesting. If you delete the file, it goes back
to having the unsaved dot
cuz that to me cooks him entirely on him saying it was deleted.
I didn't have it anymore. He's totally
>> ready our ships for assault.
>> Fire
core.
>> Oh, I can go back and get them. >> There's a whole
lot of dead air here coming up. mineral field. >> But I
will have time stamps coming up shortly. Okay,
this is where the time stamps start. I I can go back and catch
anything we miss. Okay, we'll get clips of it and stuff, but
let's start from here just cuz we have timestamps.
I want to keep it moving. Want to keep it pushing. Okay, >> come
back.
>> Yeah, we totally believe he he just went to take a [__]
guys. He went to take a
7 minute.
Definitely didn't go to make a phone call. Definitely didn't
go to contact somebody. Definitely not. >> Oh, I'm back.
How you guys doing? Actually back. Yeah, I'm back. What do you
guys thought? You guys thought the FBI abducted me or something?
>> Yo, what up, Carson's?
what the [__] >> Here's here's where the buddy
comes in and presses. Okay, >> I I just want to ask you
one. >> We'll watch this one more time. >> Did you
know that was in that links in those links? Okay. You know, >> Oh,
super aids. Thank you for the new sub. Appreciate it, buddy.
So, how did you get those? >> Appreciate you cuz I download
a lot.
I >> I understand how the go frets works. You realize But
you realize that like half of the streaming world right now thinks
you're a >> Yeah, but I mean it doesn't matter. They're
always going to think that. Like there's nothing I can say or
do. >> There's one thing that's lolly and then the other
thing is real children getting those are two different things.
>> Yeah. I dude dude there's no way his chat is hitting
him with this. There's no way the chat is hitting themselves
with this. That's crazy. Okay, he downloads a lot, guys. It's
not a big deal. Uh, sorry. There's a person who asked, who is
this? Oh, I missed this in the Twitch chat earlier. They asked,
"What are the odds Lucari just streams through it if he gets
unbanned and pulls a giant waffle?" Bro, is anybody in his audience
like even upset by this? If he just says, "I was looking up like,
will anybody in his audience even be upset? Do they even care?"
I can't imagine they care to be honest with you.
>> Yeah, I know, bro. like what
>> uh setting aside the obvious moral concerns, do you
think content should be illegal? I'm not sure, but I will always
forever just say yes. I'll be maximally
because there's no advantage to ever trying to find nuance and
ever. Anything that's even remotely adjacent, I'll just say yeah
should be illegal. Actually, anime should be illegal. Anime should
be illegal actually.
Like I think probably anything that's
people underage
is bad in my opinion.
Now there's something there in Japanese culture where it's like
not necessarily
have like cute little girls.
I think it's a little weird when you're into that as somebody
who's grown up in Western culture where we don't really have
that, right? I think if you if you think that's really cool,
you're really into that. Maybe Japanese people and growing up
in that culture that could be normalized and it's like not weird.
But if you're like a white dude from North America and you keep
like trying to go with this [__] and you're like
you're you're leaning into it. I do think it's it's bizarre to
me. But like ah man. Yeah. It's it's like a tough question. I
think means a different thing in Japan. Like it's there there's
part of it that means that and there's part of it that just means
like something a little different. It's weird. I don't fully
understand it. So I'm just like okay. think it's weird that white
dudes really like this. Are you good? >> Yeah. So, you
like disprove that because if if you think it's a joke, which
I mean I I still believe you. That's why I'm calling you. I don't
think you're a necessarily. But you realize that the longer this
drags on, the more you you they will view you as a actual >> Those
links were
like 3D real children getting abused. You realize that, right?
>> Yeah, I know, dude. That's why I
That's why I didn't download anything. But chill. Okay. I mean,
I I trust you, but I I'm really just about the perception of
it because I was also abused as a minor. So, I really just want
to know. >> I don't like Lar anymore, guys. Cuz he cheated.
He cheated cuz he's weak. He's a weak weak man. He will go back
to Epic 7 and he will never PB ever again.
>> Dude, did he just kick the guy as he says that? >> I
think he did. I think he unironically disconnects from the call
as that guy's pressing him. Oh boy.
That's a rough one, dude.
Oh, there's a KO Twitter. Let's go.
Oh, I Dude, I came so close to messaging this person on Twitter
today just to be like, "Hey, do you have any statement on like
the Lucari stuff? I think it's pretty crazy."
Oh, hold on. No, she's There's no way she throws him under the
bus. Please don't throw him under the bus. Please don't throw
him under the bus. Please don't throw him under the bus. Um,
Lucari and I broke up over a year and a half ago. When we dated,
I had asked to see his folder because I heard allegations. I
did my due diligence when I suspected something was a miss. When
I couldn't find anything crazy, I stopped suspecting. Clearly,
I was wrong. The worst I saw was NTR, but now I know he could
have hid the worst of it. I don't know why people keep associating
me with him when he has a new girlfriend and I'm getting rage
baited into a response. So, here it is.
>> Cuo goes through Lucari's DGEN folders.
>> Yo, what up? You want to tell Chad about our bonding
moment yesterday? >> Is it okay? >> Yeah, sure. You
can tell them. >> I'll do anything for her. >> You're
You're not going to hold back on what I'm going to say, right?
>> You on to the right path.
>> Whoa. Slow down. >> Ends here. >> How much
are you going to tell them?
>> Found you. >> You're going to tell my chat everything.
>> You're going to Never mind. We found out. We found out
how Lucari actually dated this person. Okay. We found out. It's
the voice. It's the voice. That's what, dude? Why was this mysterious?
Obviously, if he just tries to if he only talks to her over Discord,
he can perfectly project. Okay. She's like, she's like hanging
out with him. She's like, "Do you want to go to the bedroom?"
And he's like, "Yeah, you should go to the bedroom and call me
on Discord so we can so we can have both.
You should go to the bedroom and call me on Discord." Right now
to tell my chat
>> You're going to tell my chat everything.
>> Huh? How can you handle any?
>> You're not going to tell them everything, are you?
>> So, yesterday
I asked Lucari how much of a DJ he truly >> I can lose
>> cuz I don't think he's actually that degenerate. I think
he's like faking it >> within our grasp. >> And he
was like, "No, I'm I'm definitely a DJ." And I was like, "Okay,
prove it.
>> Screen share me
>> your folder. authority as mediator. I will watch. >> He
was like, "Are you Lucar?" You're getting cocked, bro. >> Danny
for you though. >> Show me the folder. And he spent like
>> no shot. This is her real voice. I do think it's her
real voice. I think she talks like this with other people. Hold
on. Hold on. Let me go to her YouTube or something. I'm pretty
sure this is just straight up her real voice.
Jesus Christ.
This is all It's all the most DJ animation. Here's one. >> So,
I have this big bowl. >> Here's DJ. We're going to put
in all our foods in miso soup is actually really easy to make.
>> So she does she does talk with this voice like the whole
time. Okay.
>> Okay. All right. >> 20 minutes compiling and it
turns out he's got like 10 different folders because what happens
is after a certain while he abandons a folder and starts a new
one. So he has pictures from like 6 years ago that he doesn't
even remember he has. And so >> I'll deal with this. He
spent like an hour or two >> going through >> prove
your >> six years. >> There's there's something about
Lucari being like the uh the dwarves. Okay. And his folders being
the minds of Moria. We dug too deep. We were too greedy. We dug
too deep. We found something terrible. >> Pictures feeling
sore. >> Six years. >> You're actually
of his taste. >> I'll end this quick. >> And I'm
I'm going to tell him I'm going to tell him something that uh
is wildest. I never >> Don't tell them. Don't tell them.
Don't tell them. >> You're a fake DJ. >> WHAT DO
YOU MEAN FAKE? >> Literally the same type of picture and
pose for all your freaking pictures, just different characters.
He is a fake degenerate. I thought there would be some really
depraved. It is the same thing. All the folders have the same
thing. I'm more degenerate than he is. And uh >> I believe
that 100%. I believe that.
I dude that's not even questionable. >> I just, you know,
reveal it to the chat to let you know that this guy
the whole entire time. >> We did end up watching.
>> Well, that was kind of cool.
He critiqued which parts was our favorite. And you know was really
interesting that he picked was >> he watches NTR. I'll
take >> I don't What are YOU [__] TALKING ABOUT?
THAT'S NOT EVEN THE PART I LIKED. THAT'S NOT EVEN THE PART I
LIKED. THAT'S NOT EVEN THE PART I LIKED. THAT'S NOT THE PART
I LIKED. YOU'RE [__] I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU'RE
>> What does that mean? Hold on. What does that mean? NTR.
NTR. What?
This isn't it. What is it? How do you spell it? How do you spell
it? I can't think of how Oh, Ntr.
Wait, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. What the I just realized I'm
I'm googling tags. Hold on.
Okay. Thank god nothing came up. Oh Jesus. That was that was
really stupid to just enter in and not think and just hit the
pull the trigger. NTR is an acronym with multiple meanings. Most
commonly referring to the Japanese slang term netoar.
A genre where a partner is stolen.
Ain't no way. This [__] into
you serious. Are you serious? Brother
Are we serious? Are we serious right
that image. Wait, what image? Nothing popped up. Nothing popped
up. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. We're
Jesus. Jesus Christ. Okay.
This guy's into
and his girlfriend just leaked that. I feel like she's asking
for something. >> No, that might
I can't even remember THE NAME OF IT. >> THEY WERE LIKE
[__] FIVE DIFFERENT SCENES. AND THAT WASN'T EVEN
THE PART I
NO, ALL OF THEM WERE NTR related. The first one was about how
like some girl and guy got captured by another couple and the
boyfriend had to watch the girl eat another girl out and the
other girl was like eating her out. And then later on there was
like, >> oh, there was this one girl who was coming on
to another guy and she was seducing him, but he had a girlfriend.
And so as he's like, you know, really getting it on with her,
she's like, "By the way, I called your girlfriend over and she's
coming here any moment now. If you want to put it in, you have
to choose between me or her. And Lucari was rooting for the
>> the one who's he was like the one who's really loves
this guy. She deserves to have him. Meanwhile, his girlfriend
did nothing wrong and she's just, you know, slowing down excited
to see
>> the boyfriend. And we cut to the scene where the guy's
like, you know, >> you really enjoyed >> the girl,
but we don't know which. >> YOU REALLY ENJOYED THAT SIDE,
DIDN'T >> You're dead, COMRAD. >> LET ME JUST FINISH.
Let me finish. And so all we see is like the behind the scene
where the guy is the girl and there's like these two legs and
we don't know which girl is moaning. Well, there wasn't any sound
because he was hearing his monitor. So maybe we could. But I
was like, "So which girl won?" And it was the girlfriend who
won. But Lucari was like, "Man, this made me mad." >> I
was like, "Why?" He's like, "It was the other girl." >> I
don't care. I don't care. I don't care anymore. Apparently, she
There's the statement. Such as it is. Lucari and I broke up.
She says she looked through his and didn't look any deeper. Okay,
bro. This is so insanely edited.
I' Okay. All right.
All right. Whatever. Whatever. Back to Lucari. He just kicked
the guy from the stream.
Where are we going next? Lucari.
Where are we going next?
He's just This is definitely his Discord. When he looks over
here, this is 100% his disc
100% totally cooked. The longer this goes on, the deeper a grave
you're digging for yourself. >> Mhm. Okay. deny that >> Oh,
hold on.
>> I've got like deny that
I like I didn't download. I didn't know what was in there. >> Don't
be sad that your career is over. Be happy that it happened. XQCL.
Don't be sad that your career is over. Be happy that it happened.
XQCL. Jesse vindicated. Jesse vindicated. Jesse
>> How does it end up there?
>> Okay, let me explain what happened. All right. I was
surfing a site. Okay. >> Oh, here's the full explanation.
Let's go. Let's explain. He's going to explain. He's going to
drop knowledge on us, guys. Here's how it happened. >> Explain
what happened. All right. I was surfing a site.
>> What site?
what site? What site's going on here? >> Okay.
The got downloaded. Like, I didn't trigger a download. Just got
downloaded. I opened up the text document. I saw what was in
it. I deleted the text document. I deleted the text document.
I deleted it. But the problem with Windows 11 is that even if
you delete the text document, IT APPARENTLY STILL stays there.
So, it was still there after I deleted it. >> I'VE TOLD
YOU GUYS A THOUSAND TIMES THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED. This is really
stupid to be litigating any of this on stream, to be putting
statements out from your own voice, right? This is incredibly
stupid. His lawyer is losing their mind right now.
Like I I I DUDE I'M SORRY. Like I have like a terror like three
terrible. Now here's the By the way, everybody's saying no, we
got to check the glitch. Does that work? You don't really got
to check the glitch. You just have to look at the tabs and see
that there are two tabs open. Did he Did he accidentally load
up two tabs?
How do he accidentally load up two tabs of closely related
Okay, that's that's my question is I I think that immediately
undoes everything he's saying. You do it once. Yeah, possibly
you you went to a site and it downloaded something. You open
it up and you're like, I don't know what this is. Close, delete,
or just delete. And then it keeps the text file. Why do you have
two? Why do you have two?
Why are there two?
Yeah, like one, what websites? Two, how do you have two of these
text files at the same time? This implies you were going deeper,
right? This implies you were continuing on that same train. You
were continuing with whatever you were doing. You have two things.
They're open back to back. You clearly downloaded them back to
back,
Like the idea that he accidentally downloaded one file. I could
maybe be sympathetic to that, but there's two tabs of obviously
the stuff and then whatever this is this Jason.
Like come on, man. How are we supposed to believe you? >> Four
byes of [__] hintai
on my >> Oh, hold on. You don't want to miss >> I'VE
TOLD YOU GUYS A THOUSAND TIMES THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED. LIKE I I
I I DUDE, I'm sorry. Like I have like a ter like three terab
of
on my hard drive, bro. Like like a lot.
Oh, three now. I thought it was six before. Now it's three terabytes.
>> Sometimes you go to a site, some downloads on your you
don't want it. you delete it and THAT LIKE THAT'S JUST WHAT HAPPENED,
MAN. OKAY. Like that's what happened. I'm sorry. All right.
I could almost believe you but for the second tab.
The second tab. Okay.
How do you explain the second tab, Lucari? How do you Did you
do this twice in the same session? Is that what happened? I I
get it there. Yeah. There's just so so many questions that you
have to ask here that that resolve horribly for him, right? Like,
hey, well, okay, I see you're saying that. I see what you're
saying here. You you went to the folder. So, you went to some
site and it auto downloaded something. Okay. Then you opened
that auto download. You found some weird or you I don't know
if you opened it, didn't open it. I do believe he says at one
point he went to it and saw it was bad and closed it and deleted
it. But cuz uh that's the other thing he says. There are two
options. Either he saw that link and knew it was bad
or he had to go to it to know it was bad. If he knew it was bad,
I don't think anybody sees like all couples links. Why is that
bad even? There's nothing in the text that makes it bad. You
have to really be a knower to know why it's bad, right?
Yeah. There's just so many different things going on here that
he's really getting cooked by, man. >> Like I don't know
how many times I have to explain this, but that's what happened.
I just Dude, let's just move the on, please. >> What What
do you guys think? You guys think anyone's moving on from this?
In your experience of watching streamers for as long as anyone
here has, does the chat move on? Does the chat just go, "Oh,
you know what, bro? You know what, brother? Actually, we let
this one go. We're just going to let this one go." You're right,
Lucari. We should just let this one go.
Nah, nah,
nah. No one's going to [__]
That's true.
Little bit, dude. There's no moving on.
Dude, the Chris Hansen is crazy, too. He just keeps getting the
same Chris Hansen spammed in his chat. Brother, >> it's
literally a text document. That was >> I love you. Kind
regards, Jeffrey
>> Send the investigation, bro. I don't have any of this
[__] on my PC, man. Oh my god. >> Oh, I've
heard that before. I don't have any of that
on my computer. I've heard that. I've heard that one before.
I don't have any. I never retain
on my computer.
I've heard it. I've heard this before. The same excuse. Oh my
goodness. >> Our scouts are reporting. The Dominion is
attempting to fight back. The >> capital ships have docked
within the Spear of Adon. They await your >> What's up,
brother? Actually, watch.
now fuel bags like my friends like upset the game. >> Lari
scenes getting spammed. Lax scenes get getting spammed. Okay,
none of it's
None of it's good. It's all a little
>> Okay, we can go to the next time stamp if uh if there's
nothing else going on
>> Oh, here. >> Don't talk. Get a lawyer. >> Get
a lawyer for what? How is a lawyer going to help me, man?
>> Um, for one, they would have told you to shut the stream
off.
For one, they would have said, "Hey, how about you shut that
stream off right now?"
Right? Is a is a lawyer going to tell everyone that like I'm
innocent? Like I don't
like I don't understand what you're saying, dude. Like can a
lawyer publicly speak on my behalf and explain
Uh they could that that is actually something they could do technically.
Yes.
But they would immediately tell you to not incriminate yourself
further.
That'd be the most important part.
>> Actually, they can do that.
>> Yes. Wait, let me actually read what people are saying.
Full manhandling. Wait, I LIKE WHAT THIS GUY SAYS. FULL MANHANDLING.
Ban anyone.
>> I mean, I am open to getting investigated. Like, actually,
cuz I like I know I'm innocent, so I'm open to get >> I
have nothing to hide. The FBI can look at my hard drives. >> I'm
actually open for it. If that is enough to like disprove this,
then please, by all means, we're going to take it way too seriously.
Well, yeah, obviously, as we just saw, lacks awareness. Another
trade of top laner.
I'll just lure I'll just lure her up, bro. [__] it.
>> I'll just lure her up. It's fine. >> That would
not be the hell is this >> that would not be a bad idea.
>> Tempest siege artillery. Wait, so there's like a protos
guardian.
>> Does anyone know what he like?
>> Stop lying to us.
>> We know it. You know it. If this is really going to
be your last stream, then the least you can do and the least
we deserve is a proper goodbye. Don't go out lame like this.
Is this really how you want to be remembered?
I told you the truth. There's nothing else I can say.
>> Told you the truth. There's nothing else I can say.
No, no, no. You're wrong. You've not told us the truth. You're
lying. But also, does anybody know the Golden Eye scene I'm looking
for? I'm looking for the golden eye scene where it's like Boris
pulling apart all of the hard drives or whatever at the end of
the thing.
Is it somewhere here?
I'm thinking I'm thinking of this guy when he's like pulling
all of the
That's what the car is doing. He's like, I'm open to being investigated
and then he goes and he just starts like ripping hard drives
out of his out of his computer getting ready to magnet all of
them. Put them all in the microwave. Okay, I'm open to being
investigated. I can't find a specific scene. The scene from Golden
Eye
at the beginning. Oh, is >> BUT WHAT ELSE DO YOU WANT ME
TO SAY? I HAVE NOTHING ELSE I CAN SAY, BRO.
I literally told you the truth. You can believe me or you can't
believe me. It is what it is. I like 2D, though. I will say that.
That's about it.
>> Valor is eternal. >> That's them playing that
soundboard. That's not me. I don't do that. >> It's not
funny.
>> I'm the
[__]
The [__] This is the FBI. We have a warrant. Merge.
Merge. >> The toaster. Like magnets going over the hard
drives. Did he make it?
>> Lari being open to investigation right here. Okay. Lucari
isn't smart enough to do any of this. I think that's a vaguely
racist comment. DON'T APPRECIATE THAT. >> JOKING ABOUT
IT. WHAT THE [__] DO YOU JUST WRITING YOUR own narrative?
YOU'RE JUST WRITING YOUR own narrative, man. What the else do
you WANT ME TO DO? WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
OH, I'M SO SORRY.
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
I DIDN'T [__] DO ANYTHING. THAT'S WHY I'M NOT CRYING
AND SOBBING, [__] I DIDN'T [__] DO ANYTHING,
DUMBASS. YOU JUST WANT ME TO BE GUILTY SO BAD. SHUT THE UP.
Jesus Christ. I'm so sick of this.
You want me to be guilty so bad. It's crazy. It's actually crazy,
bro. And it's sad cuz you have no life and you're [__]
miserable. That's why. [__] you. >> Yeah, I
I totally believe this guy. This guy's not going through it at
all. This guy's totally innocent. This guy's not going to have
any problems, right? I think this guy's totally fine. No problems.
No problems. No problems whatsoever. This guy's totally innocent.
>> I said my peace, man. I'm done with this, bro. I'm going
to keep streaming
viewers day. I'm done with this [__] YOU COMING AT
ME. YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW IF I'M GUILTY OR NOT. You >> just
end stream. You're making
>> your image. Why do you links on your notepad? Why are
they even there? >> Actually, YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GOING TO
DO? I'M GOING TO KEEP [__] STREAMING. MATTER OF FACT,
I'M GOING TO FREE MORE BECAUSE [__] you, >> dude.
Do not do this. Do not let this happen to you, okay? Never let
this happen to you. This is the worst thing you could possibly
do. Yeah, this is a verifiable like certified AAA grade crash
out now. Okay. Uh, actually, I'm just going to keep streaming.
You guys keep saying I should get offline. Uh, no. I'm going
to keep streaming now. This couldn't possibly go badly for me.
You guys, you don't even KNOW IF I'M INNOCENT. DON'T YOU? What
do you mean? You don't even know if I'm Aren't you just going
to say I'm innocent? Why do you say it that way? You don't even
know if I'm guilty. You don't even know if I'm guilty. You don't
even know if I'm innocent. Why not just say you're innocent?
Why not just say, "No, I didn't do anything. I DIDN'T HAVE ANY
FILES DOWNLOADED." YEAH, but what what's happening, man?
Stream until he gets banned. So smart. Uh, listen. So, they usually
don't ban you if you're live. Maybe that's what he was going
for. He's like, "This is my last stream. They won't ban me if
I'm live. If I just stay live forever, I'll be fine." Maybe that's
WHAT HE THOUGHT. OH,
WHAT A WHAT a golden era. Dude,
could could the drama of 2026 could this have kicked off any
harder? Is there just something about January that makes people
they're like new year, new me. Time to go insane,
Dude, we have the Turkey Tom stuff. We got this guy, bro. We've
got the Oh, the
the Marbles Marvel rivals drama, bro. We have Trumpet trying
to invade Greenland.
Holy [__] A all of the Aiden stuff, dude. The Aiden
stuff. I don't even Who's Aiden? What happened with Aiden? I
forget. Aiden was trying to dock some dude. Well, listen. Now
we have actual amongst massive streamers. My goodness.
This is this is some crazy [__] Ice and NICK LEE.
OH, ICE DIDDY. YEAH. Oh my god. There's so many things happening.
YOU OBVIOUSLY NEVER GONE TO A virus site before WHERE JUST GETS
DOWNLOADED on your PC, huh? Without your permission. FIT HAPPENS
ALL THE TIME,
Nobody believes that. It's just a virus site. It's just a virus
site, bro. It's a virus site.
Why'd you get multiple files downloaded? Why did you get a file
downloaded from the virus site, open it, and then get another
file downloaded from the virus site, and then open it
Why'd you do that? Why' you stay on the virus site and open another
file from the virus site? Can someone explain?
Can someone explain?
Can anyone Can anyone make it make sense? He did say at one point,
yes, that he wanted to navigate directly. Sorry, he navigated
directly, saw what was there, and then deleted it. Right. He
did say that because he's a
Oh boy.
Done with this [__] man. Not going to sit here and
take THIS ANYMORE. MY CHAT IS WAY TOO TOXIC FOR ME TO BE PUT
DOWN BY SOME LSF
WHO ARE VIRTUE SIGNALING ACTING LIKE THEY ALREADY KNOW THE FULL
STORY.
>> [__] you, man. >> Oh,
this was the other thing that kind of him. I I think he could
have just paused and explained or something right away, but he
was just caught so off guard. He He I I'll give, you know, Chud
his laurels. The first time this dropped, I'm like, "Oh, all
he has to do is go offline and he's gonna be fine." And Chud
just kept hammering that this guy's a this guy's a this guy's
a and then it was getting he's encouraging people to post LSF.
And eventually the pressure broke Lucari. Okay. If he if he hadn't
stayed live, if Chud hadn't been pressuring this guy, if Miskip
hadn't been pressuring this guy, he might have gone offline and
like saved this whole thing.
But he had to stay online. He had to prove to his audience that
he's the big man. He's the he's the main dude in charge. Okay,
he stayed live
and he melted the down.
So, you know, W miss Wch Chut.
They called it. I Dude, I But I'm positive. I'm still positive
that he could have gone offline and been totally fine. Like he
could not totally fine. He would have gotten like hit, but it
wouldn't have been a problem. Everybody in his audience is already
like pseudo on board with everything that's in those files. Okay.
His audience don't give a [__] They'll just have
to They'll just have to signal they care now. >> Enough
is enough, bro. Say what you want, bro. I don't give a If you
want to believe me, you can believe me. If you DON'T WANT TO
BELIEVE ME, THEN don't believe me.
Life is going to move the on.
Is it?
>> Hi, Lagari. Renlux here. Don't worry. This happens to
me all the time. It'll all blow over soon enough. >> That's
okay, bro. Was that a Was that a DG or joke right there? Hold
on. Did I miss that? >> Let me hear that donation again.
I think there's a DG or joke right there. >> Hagari Renlux
here. Don't worry. This happens to me all the time. It'll all
blow over soon enough. >> That's okay.
>> I'm just going to keep playing my >> Dude, that's
all Lucari's got to do. Just pivot to Destiny's community.
Bro, this guy this guy's way funnier than food shops.
This guy's way funnier than food shops. He's just got to pivot
into Destiny's community. He'll be fine. >> Damn. That's
what I like to do. Anyways,
>> uh color. I have no idea. >> Such hubris.
>> Control what they did not understand.
>> It's always hubris with the Terran. Get too close to
a black hole and it will crush you. We once thought the same
of the Talddareim All Alarak. We believed you mindless and obedient
slaves.
>> We thought you were weak, impure.
>> Saves viruses.
>> THAT VIRUS WAS [__] SAVE THEMSELVES. THAT'S
HOW THEY WORK. >> Perhaps we
>> dude. Uh not good. Not good to go down the virus, dude.
When you are in a drama, okay, in you know, it's good that the
cooked himself or whatever here.
but when you are in a drama,
don't start weaving into stuff you don't know. This guy doesn't
know tech to claim that it's a virus. He's going to make a bunch
of claims because he's saying it's a virus that he can't verify,
he can't know, and he's going to look like a liar.
Even if he were innocent, which he's not, but even if he were
innocent, he's himself over right here. >> ACTED TOO RASHLY.
>> THEY
such illegal [__] ON YOUR [__] PC. THAT'S
JUST HOW THEY WORK. EL TEMPMPLAR, is there ever a moment when
your people do not doubt themselves? No, Artanis. Extermination
was the only course. The hybrid leave nothing. >> That's
not true. Yes, it is. That's not true. Yes, it is. VIRUSES DOWNLOAD
THEMSELVES ALL THE TIME. It's like he used to know stuff about
computers like 10 years ago and he's like trying to use his Windows
knowledge from 10 years ago before they made it like usable for
everybody and he doesn't know what Windows 11 is like. He doesn't
know how Windows Defender works. He knows nothing, right? He
just plays video games on his computer now. >> Obviously,
I've never gone to a
>> Okay, now hold on. That's the perfect moment to point
out that this Lucari guy been clicking strange links for a long
ass time. Okay, let me go to Oh, wait. What? Hold on. Let me
go to this link right here. Exhibit A.
My Discord account got hacked again. Don't click any links for
me. And then apparently his Discord account was like like Yeah.
linking random crazy of different people being like, "Go here,
log into this." Dude, this guy This guy is the dumbest addict.
What the
What do you mean your Discord account got hacked again? What
do you mean? This is like the kind of message that works on Lucari,
by the way. He like clicks on this. He's like, "Oh, yeah. I'll
go here with the password." Yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Dude,
rough. It's It's crazy. Someone accident that works. >> Robotics
are now on Disney.
>> Welcome back.
>> Who knew cheese beef? Who knew? >> It turns out
Turkey Tom was correct even though he didn't take his own advice.
The never goon thing. That is totally true. You can goon yourself
for Turkey Tom's done it. Lucari's done it. It is the end of
many people.
Revan scar has fallen and through its death the templar has >> got
my next time step. It's like a minute forward. >> Actually
of the
>> I you can just tell if you just watch his face I can
tell he's like two seconds away from saying another thing every
single time.
>> Actually Miskf linked it to me. He did. >> Uhhuh.
Did he? Now I think at this point he's probably being informed
by his audience that Msk is rereaming him. Misgif is like camping
this guy and farming him.
At some point also, low tier god pops in. We might have to check
out some of the low tier god highlights. I don't know if there's
anything good there, but I did notice at some point that low
tier god also started farming
>> The ghost put those Okay, first off, you're
because the files >> Hold on. I got to back this up because
we we got a fantastic quote in chat.
total BDSM freak in the kick chat says, "This kind of stuff for
real makes me want to stop watching porn entirely." Thank you,
total BDSM freak.
Thank you. Thank you for your commitment to celibacy.
Thank you. >> You did. >> The ghost put those Okay,
first off, you're
because the files weren't on my PC. They're in a link. Like,
>> LIKE, WHAT THE [__] THEY'RE IN A >> TEXTBOOK
gaslighting from a manipulative zero accountability lowly weirdo.
Have the slightest resemblance of shame to own up to your [__]
>> You got caught. End of story. Everyone saw it plain
as day. >> My bad. >> Like that doesn't just appear.
Come on. >> It doesn't. You're right. Totally. Yeah, >> dude.
Sitting here with like a with unfiltered TTS
like willing to accept calls on Discord. This is the Oh my goodness,
man.
Every lawyer in the world just like cringing horribly at this
that he didn't log off immediately.
Bro, these donos. These donos pressing and he thinks, "Oh, I
I'll throw up my hands. It's the cot meme. Look guys, I'm caught.
Look guys, I'm caught. I'm caught. I'm caught." Now you'll stop
talking about it, right? Nope. >> Nope. Got me.
>> It is an armada.
Behold the death fleet under A's command. poised on laying waste
to all life in the sector. Then we had best >> I'm about
to hit the next time stap right here. >> Rush here. >> Listen,
if you want to talk to me about it, you can DM me. I'll literally
explain everything. >> Cannot be rushed. Eats rights demand.
>> I'll literally respond to everything. I will listen.
DM me. I'll explain >> We are in orbit above a hostile
world with an imposing fleet. And you speak of
>> My Twitter DMs are open. My Discord DMs are open. an
entire >> after my 20our stream. I'll explain it
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on. Lax community wouldn't have
let him try to stream through it unressed. He had no choice but
to try to go through. No, he had a choice on when to do that.
That's the issue. Cheese Beef, he could have very easily said,
"Okay, I'm going to log off. I'm going to get my statement collected.
I'm going to figure out what my story is, and then I'm going
to go live and explain it." But instead, he tried to do it live
on the fly. And I think honestly I think that's good for all
of us because now I'm like very suspicious of him, right? When
he makes up so many lies on the fly.
If he had gone offline, gotten all this together and made a statement.
He could have gone through this with some plausible statement,
right?
And I think he could have gotten through this. But honestly,
he lied so many times about what how this happened. He said so
many like contraindicating things, so many contradicting things
going through this that I don't know how you I don't know how
you resolve this into something that makes sense anymore. It's
just it's it's exploded. Content overflowth thankfully. Yes,
the content cornucopia continues.
>> You will aid me. >> I'll go through my messages
one by one. >> I will remove the powder from this >> At
what point is the excuse going to be its harm reduction? This
ritual must be >> At what point is the excuse going to
beeps out reduction? Weeps.
>> This bargain grows less appealing by the
>> The golden armada has devastated the se. >> You
got to admit, you got to admit the weeb track record's not great.
All right, you got to you just got to admit it. Accept it. The
weeb track record not
>> Aerys will not tell me about this. Oh my [__]
I didn't think about that. >> I wish to know more about
this rair
your ritual combat.
To understand rair you must first understand the sacred chain
of ascension that ultimately links to Aman.
Each of us is shackled to his will and to the will of he who
is
hormone. >> Eliminate them before I proceed. >> Hold
on. This is the This is lashes
>> Oh, it's a stress hormone. >> Eliminate before
I proceed. >> I feel like I live perpetually stressed.
So like I feel like normal honestly.
>> Oh, wait. Hold on. I need to go back further. Was that
a cortisol joke? >> Challenge of Rexir. Preparations must
be >> I need to see if that's a cortisol joke. >> Decrees
of old >> the clavvicular reference. >> Cortisol.
What did that mean? >> Malash will surely attempt to interfere.
>> You're letting your cortisol levels rise, bro. That's
not good for you. Is Aaron his girlfriend? I don't know who his
girlfriend is.
>> I don't know who his girlfriend is, but Cuo wants you
to know that it is not her. Okay? She is not with Lucari. She's
done being tied to Lucari. This guy's a Get him out of her sight.
Okay, just so you know, we broke up a year and a half ago.
Dude, honestly, I thought I [__] too, but after playing
the protos campaign, they've kind of grown on me.
>> These are Malash's guardians. >> Oh, it's a stress
hormone. >> Eliminate them before I proceed. >> I
feel like I live perpetually stressed, so like I feel like normal,
honestly. >> Wait, what is that strange fog?
>> Tarzine.
It flows and cycles from the chasms of slain, bringing us closer
to the void. Those are two forces will be able to manif >> I'll
be honest a little side thing just on my I know a lot of people
are just here for the kari stuff. Okay, but on a personal level
I've never played Legacy of the Void and he's spoiling like all
of Legacy for the of the void for me. I never played it and at
some point I'll play it. I played all of Heart of the Swarm.
I never played the single player for Legacy of the Void and he's
spoiling the whole thing for me and it's kind of up that during
this massive drama he's going to spoil Legacy of the Void for
me. It's really [__] It's It's just >> Confess
until the flows subside. >> Just zoom just zoom in on his
voice and not hear all of the things being said.
>> They do not possess their full power here yet. >> You're
not playing 20 years after release. You don't get to claim spoilers.
Wait, when did Legacy of the Void come out? Legacy of the Void.
Legacy of the Void's like what? 2015. It's like a decade ago.
It's not 20 >> Strike at your base ruthlessly.
>> How can I watch the VOD from the start? Go to kick.com/jsdl
and you can watch the VOD from the start there. Go to my VODs.
You can watch it from the start. >> I thought you promised
an assured victory. Allarak,
>> you enjoy a challenge, do you not?
>> Very well.
>> Will pursue the god. >> Download and deleted file
>> when the terazine flows. >> Wait, can you actually
find that? >> Endure the onslaught. >> Can you actually
find that? Hold on.
Will that actually? Hold on. Let me see. Hilagari. What exactly
is the aim of quote unquote virus sites that download numerous
text files that open themselves that link to deposits of cheese
pizza and beastiality videos?
>> What a nefarious virus. That's actually a fantastic
point I didn't think of. What an amazing virus. I'm going to
make a virus that just pops child links up in your text files.
I This is a great Dude, this is a great idea. I made a virus
that's going to open up a link on your computer and you're not
even going to see it. It's going to open up in your notepad,
okay? And it's going to just have the text of a link that leads
to child eventually. What? Five head virus. Amazing stuff,
Getting close to it. Okay. Um,
what do we do here?
What do we do here? What do we do here? I think Hold on. I don't
know if I'm getting close to it. Let me see. Dung Devil gave
me the time stamp for when this pops up in this VOD. We're not
getting close to it. We're still more than an hour away, Maximus,
from where that pops up here. We're going to start skipping forward
a little
>> From the recycling,
where do you see it? Can you see it if it's been deleted from
the recycling bin? >> I like that. Okay,
people are like, "Hey, go pop this stuff up and then that'll
tell us the truth." And what does he do? What does Lucari do?
Lucari
deletes his he he removes his desktop. Okay, he removes his desktop.
That's amazing. Hold on. You know what I should do is I should
figure out in the background, how do I get like a filter going
over this? Like if I wanted to filter my entire browser, can
I add an effect filter that's a blur? Is there like a blur effect
that I could put on?
Okay, there's a sharpen effect.
Is there anything I can do? How do you do like a blur over
H
I'll figure it out. Give me a second. We got a lot of time. How?
Oh, there's there's extensions to do it,
bro. Doesn't know. Dude, I don't
like I know how PCs work, but I don't know how this works. He's
saying, "Why were there two notepads?" I don't understand what
what you mean by that.
>> Oh, why are there two files? Thank you. Yes, somebody's
asking question. >> Some age play with one of the mottos.
It's over, boy. This is what you got for no respecting Epstein
and my goat clvicular. You going to be eating dead rats from
now on in that. Is having illegal site links illegal. Does that
count as something? Can a link be illegal? Yes, I believe a link
can be
Um, it would depend on how direct it is. And maybe you get out
of jail, maybe you get like a get out of jail free card by only
having links to links and there's nothing like necessarily illegal
there. Maybe legally he's okay. But the issue is he's not like
we can judge it for what it is, right? The the idea that he has
a legal loophole possibly doesn't prevent us from judging this
for what it >> D boy, respect, >> dude. He's going
silent. Okay, here's the next part.
It'll be happening soon.
>> you already
know that
and lowly. You're really telling us you have the moral compass
to draw the line at the links you posted. P.S. He is shift deleting
the real illegal [__] >> I guess it came with
the
pack or
They got downloaded on my You opened it? >> Wait, hold
on. I need to listen to that again. What the [__]
did he say?
Yeah. What the [__] did you just say? >> You
opened it.
No, it had to have come with a pack,
but I deleted everything. So,
I guess it was like additional. I would mind if we liberated
them. >> Download the pack again. >> What is that?
What does that mean? The pack. What is he talking about? The
pack that that came with the pack.
Why is he speaking, dude? His lawyer's going to lose it on him.
What the [__] are YOU TALKING ABOUT? THE PACK.
SORRY, I'm also trying to get this blur thing working for later
on in the stream. BUT WHAT IS HE TALKING ABOUT? THE PACK OF LINKS.
What is he saying? He went to the site and downloaded the pack.
What is this? >> Shut up. >> I have to go to the
site. Pringle, thank you for the 15 months >> that gave
it to me
>> without my permission.
>> I don't know if I want to do that. Pretty sure I'm never
going to set it >> Here, hold on. We're going to we're
going to take this. >> Dude, your life is over and you
are sitting here wasting one of your last three days embarrassing
yourself. We all see through this attempt to laugh this off.
Good riddance,
Lari, just log off the car. Please just log off. How is there?
Here's the question. Okay, here's the real question. How in God's
name is there two more hours of this? How is there two more hours
of him doing the same thing like coming up with stupid excuses
and his whole chat grilling him? TTS is coming and calling him
a
How How does it go for two more hours? And by the way, I think
the only reason it ends is because he gets banned. Dude,
at least he's making money. Speaking of making money, guys, if
you like the content, go ahead, throw a couple subs my way. If
you're watching on Twitch, throw me your primer, okay?
Throw me primers now. All right, we're trying to add more time
to the stream. Every $30 adds another hour to the stream. So,
go ahead, sub on kick. Throw a TTS message in, okay? Exclamation
point, donate in the chat. We'll give you the TTS links. Uh,
appreciate all the support, guys. Let's continue on with the
content. I'll lawyer up, bro. I'm open to an investigation. >> Was
it perma? No, it's one week on it's not perma on Twitch. You
can't tell on kick, but it's not perma on Twitch. Oh, ban came
way after he's off offline. I thought the Twitch ban was what
>> I thought the Twitch ban ended his stream. That's what
I was told. But you know what? It's fine. If the Twitch ban didn't
end his stream, then he just ended himself. That's cool. Now,
the kickban came way after he's off stream. Kickban came, I think,
a little bit >> Make your off on his own. Okay. All right.
All right,
>> you went to >> Oh, hold on.
>> We've got We've got a sub coming in. Thank you very
much to Oh, god. It's Twitch Prime. It's Twitch Prime. Thank
you very much, Lee, for the primer. Appreciate it, dude.
>> How the is this not a perma? Did he not show links on
stream or am I wrong? He showed links that link to Yes. But very
I mean, sorry, we should be clear. That's what like Reddit detective
said. I have to be careful about going through these Reddit threads.
Where's the initial one? There's like an initial Reddit thread.
Okay. And this is like a repost. I just have to make sure that
the list of the files isn't here. But there are
there are some people on Reddit who went through this.
I pulled up one of them the images already. I think it's not
that one, that one. This there are people who like went through
this stuff and were like, "Okay, just know there are Reddit detectives,
okay, professional,
professional
who are ready to go through this and investigate and they're
like, "Yeah, this guy's cooked." Yeah, this guy's cooked.
All right, this guy's very cooked. How do they Yes, little white
hat. Yes, probably not white hat. Probably just people who are
drama drama frogs and at the same time, but white hat in this
case. Okay.
The only the only thing that could stop a bad P is a good PA
just like an FBI like squad of who are willing to go through
and look at all of this for them. Okay. All regular people are
like I can't do it man. They've got like a squad of who to go
through and check all the the actual
>> to
on another PC to to turn off stream and continues to selfinccriminate.
Bro definitely has all the files still in the recycle bin after
trying to hide the evidence.
nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope.
You know what I need? You know what I need here? No. You know
what we all need? We need the Emirou statement. Will Emirou of
all people
sell Lucari out? Will she turn her back on him? I think as long
as Emirou is even tacitly supporting Lucari, he can continue.
If if the Emir support fails, I don't know. We might have to
call a wellness check-in. Okay. >> What the >> silence?
Silence in this case is support. OMG, it's OG. It's Silence is
support in this case. Okay. If she just remains silent, that
will be her supporting him. That will be him being able to continue
on. All right. >> Am I just dead? Like, what the hell is
>> Hold on. She's just as bad as him. That's not true.
She just pulls a lot of viewers from his type of audience, like
his exact, you know, demographic. All right. She may appeal to
the same people, but she's not as bad as him, as far as I know.
>> We sense the base is under attack.
>> Hold on. Shouldn't have taken my hypnotic dagger, bud.
Shouldn't have taken my hypnotic dagger, bud.
Who gets the last laugh in the end? Is old pirate
This is what happens when you're an [__] on the internet.
Okay, you take my hypnotic dagger even though I'm the level to
wield it. You take my hypnotic dagger. Ah, we can't forgive that.
We can't forgive that at all.
>> Wait, am I actually just dead? What the [__]
is that? >> Oh no. Transmit. >> The terazine will
rise shortly, my warriors. Be vigilant. >> Void rays can
now be warped in at our Stargate. They are ideal for intercepting
foes in the battle ahead.
>> Well done, Face.
>> The horse video is not >> here. Hold on. Hold
on. Right here. >> Is this like force got linked the horse
video? It's not like he wanted to watch it. Is it like the Forson
thing where somebody objectively like linked it in his chat and
he clicked on it because he's a or is it more like you opened
up some private that you didn't do on stream that is only on
you and then you leaked that dude? It's like entirely different.
It's not even remotely the same. It's like completely different.
The is this really talking about?
>> The veil between this world and the void is lifting.
Aman's forces will arrive
cope/ kop/verb
verb cope third person present copes past tense cop past participle
copes gerand or present participle coping of a person deal effectively
with something difficult his ability to cope with
>> they're hitting him with the literal coke [__]
>> Okay, hold on. >> 3:27. Is he silent this whole
time?
>> We saw the links. >> You are a sick >> animal
videos. Cheese pizza. Ter special place in hell for you. You
disgusting freak. You shouldn't be in the pit. You should be
under it.
>> He took that one stoically. Okay. He took that one stoically.
That one didn't [__] with him. So, listen. He no
longer feels. Okay. He can >> can't afford to be.
>> You must construct additional pylons.
>> Hi, I'm Saul Goodman. Did you know that you have rights?
The Constitution says you do. And so do I. I believe that until
proven guilty, every man, woman, and child in this country is
innocent. And that's why I cry for you. Although you better call
Saul.
Last thing you see before getting slimed out in the kindergarten
playground >> slowly
and painfully.
>> My people will fight with honor even when we are fighting
for you. But first we must establish our defenses. >> Hold
on. I zoom out to see where the next time stamp is.
>> Oh god.
>> I was able to scan the Tarine mother ships in this region.
Right here is the >> carrying shipments of solarite.
>> I don't think our low if we >> What do you like
about the
whoa, whoa. Let's not get into the Let's not get into calling
somebody an ape. Okay, let's Whoa. Dude, I understand he's a
but racism. Racism seems a little out of balance here. Okay,
>> I don't think this low IQ.
>> What do you like about the animal prawn? Do you prefer
puppies or dogs? God, bro,
>> Prismatic Core online.
>> Okay,
I think we go a little bit without any comment here. We're going
to three. This is an old chat. >> Preparations of your
climb.
>> Yeah,
dude. As this is unfolding, I was sitting in Chudlo's chat just
typing and I'm like, "Dude, can a can a man not off to a barely
legal teenager getting by a donkey in the privacy of his own
home? Does he really have to does that really mean we have to
cancel him? Can a man not enjoy a unique niche situation in the
privacy of his own home?"
Oh boy. Oh boy.
>> Team McIntyre. Hope you're doing well.
Lucari stream kind of is
normal day on the job.
>> Is it though? Is it a normal day on the >> Lucari,
this is FBI Director Cash Patel. We have been informed.
Sir, sir,
retain the contents of your hard drive. We are on the way. >> Of
some disturbing evidence. See you
See you soon, bro. >> See you soon.
Go to the next TTS, which is right gear.
>> Say what you will about the allegations.
>> Damn, your stream title looks bad in retrospect. For
what it's worth, I believe you. Stay strong, bro. Yol. >> Wait,
what was his stream title? Hold on. Wait, what was the stream
title? That looks bad in retrospect. Anyone says I believe in
you king. Also try Enfield. It has anthropomorphic animal.
>> Insane stream. You will not believe your eyes. Tyrone
is back. Vote for dude.
>> Oh no. Oh no.
>> Maybe we should fly a bit.
>> Fog is fading.
>> Is it Lucari's funeral? This is Lucari's funeral. Unfortunately,
he gave the primary eulogy at his own funeral. Here we're watching
it right now. It is moving. Okay, I'm actually in tears watching
this unfold. I'm actually in tears. I'm moved.
What? This man has sacrificed himself.
He is a martyr for all drama streamers everywhere. Okay. He was
like, "Oh, you think 2026 drama is insane? Watch me leak that
I'm a
and you know, we got to give it up to him." I didn't have enough
content. I didn't have enough content. And Lucari decided that
he was going to save me. Okay. He has
He's delivered me from damnation. Okay. He's delivered me from
having to cover like Turkey Tom stuff or Aiden stuff. I just
get to cover a 3,000 4,000 viewer streamer.
Leak that he's an actual on stream. You love to say time is there
to slay my >> What exactly is it you find attractive about
nudist families? Could the passwords to secret sites help us
understand? Oh, right. That was all just a virus. Oh, no. Someone
sent it to you. Just like force in Guy's heart. >> Love
from Paul madeore me.
>> Tarine ships are heading towards our nexus. Hierro,
>> bring them down. >> Crazy Slick M's Keefari.
The list grows longer by the day. Robb's friend Slisk is the
real Epstein's list. Eric Lamont Robbins, we know what you are.
It's only A MATTER OF TIME.
>> STOP. NO, BRO. PLEASE.
>> Anything but that. >> Our pylon is under attack.
>> Is it me or what race? >> Uh, the E-ROB, dude.
Ero's not happy. >> hold on. We go forward a little bit.
>> Right here is the CTS. Give it a sec. >> Winter
storm or something.
>> Oh, he almost got off track. He almost started talking
about something else. You want just a >> By the way, I've
noticed that these two little girls Okay. Am I the only one who
sees this? Am I crazy or do these two little girls from this
gift? Is this not the same thing as
Hold on. Maybe I don't have the tweet up. I feel like these are
the two little girls in the bikinis from his
from his weird ass stream over here. Hold on. Am I Am I recognizing
this correctly?
Is this the same thing? It is the same thing.
That's the two little girls from this >> Like a counter
argument
>> and you don't act like a like a like a piece of >> No,
it's like these two girls are the same girls who are like jumping
around in this one. >> Hold on. >> There's going
to be a winter storm or
>> Wait, did I go back? Yeah, these two. These two right
here. These two right here are like the same little girls. He's
like got >> consistent references. >> Wonky nose.
>> So many clips have been posted. Trust me. After we get
through the actual drama, like him melting down, we will be going
through every single Lari
degenerate take. Okay, every single one. We'll go through all
of it. We'll hit up all of it. We're going to we're going to
really make a long segment out of this. Okay, this is going to
be everything. Those girls are just midgets. Clearly 18 plus.
Those girls are clearly 18. Yeah, I don't think so. I don't I
don't think so. 24-hour stream. That's true. We do need to collect
donations to go very long today so that we can cover all of all
of the previously questionable that Lucari has said, viewed,
endorsed on his
>> Hello, Private Huff. Thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it, man. >> Lari Cash Patel here again. We have the watch
and he'll see you in Valhalla.
The fog gap again.
>> Make your preparations if you're so
>> Fongo has donated three shekels to the shalom. This
is my lawyers. Mien Ross clavvicular will be suing you unless
you play heel by Kanye West right now. And remember, respect
respect you boy. It's over. Not trying to defend you, but Miz
is talking all that while he used to date the biggest and on
Twitch Emiru.
>> you know that is a good point that Miz talks a lot of
while he you know it was think about having kids with the biggest
on Twitch. That is true. That's actually a good point from that
chatter from that donator. That's a fantastic point
>> that is a very good point. I have returned you.
>> The drama frogs are crazy, bro. They just like >> how
like how the what? Nothing to do with these people.
>> What the hell? Drama frogs are crazy. We're here.
>> I don't know what this one is. We're going to the next
step. I spent a total of $12 now and I keep having to click a
text link from my bank because they have no idea why the I'm
sending you money. Anyway, don't look at your mod list. Your
entire social circle is watching and making fun of you right
now.
>> Oh, this is another thing that pops up. Like literally
everybody is watching this. Like Emiru is watching this. Ken's
watching this. Everybody who's like close to him, all of his
mods are there watching him melt down. Like all of the OTK people
are there watching at this precise moment in time. Uh I think
Msk pulls this up. I'll try to find the Msk clip where he PULLS
THIS UP. GIVE ME A
>> You have not enough. >> Someone screenshot my
Muslak.
>> Aon's forces are gone. Now's your chance to attack the
guardians. >> We meet the >> Oh, it's not on it's
not there. I need to find it on Twitter.
Yeah. No, some of the mods left. some of the mods left, but there
are other mods that are obviously VIPs in the >> We're
get pulled in.
>> Have you come to bear witness to the
>> Attention all,
please stand for your leader, Dram.
May the cheese pizzas and warn our end, but a new beginning.
Do not fear death,
fear
a
>> Here's the clip right here. Here's the clip right here.
>> My mod list.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. He He says, "Don't screenshot
my mod list."
>> Also, Misk, sort your audio levels out. If you're going
to be a drama streamer, sort your audio levels out. Holy [__]
It's unbearable, dude. I can't even hear what Lucari's saying
every time there's a clip of you. Holy man.
>> Oh, what are you going to do? Unmod >> Now's your
chance to attack the
>> bro. Even Darion's watching.
>> Bro, Trains watching.
>> Train wrecks TV. Train wrecks TV is >> Literally,
everyone that you were friends with is watching, bro. Simply's
watching. Nim is watching. >> Have you come to bear witness
to the
>> Everyone that that cared about you. >> Please
stand for your leader son. May the cheese pizzas and warm. >> What
was the view count? It was only like 4 and a halfk 5k. He didn't
get that many viewers.
>> But I I truly believe there were like as many big Twitch
streamers watching this as like regular folk. There's like there
are like drama people watching it. That's a huge chunk of it.
There's Lucari's audience watching. That's a huge chunk of it.
And then there are a big chunk of Twitch streamers, too. Tons
of people. >> Canoe in there.
>> Do not fear death,
fear.
>> Oh, he hit 9K. Oh, I didn't see the 9K. That was later
today.
>> I was asleep at that point.
>> I saw him at like four and a half to 5K. What is he
at miz? He's at 5.3 right
Okay, bro. Miz Miz has just reveled in farming this guy's death.
Okay, Ms. I didn't realize what Demon Time was. All right, I
You think I hate You think I hate someone? You think I hate another
streamer on the internet? Wait until you see Msk cover Lucari
and just like lean just kneel on this guy's neck for like four
hours in a row, five hours in a row, six hours in a row. Okay,
Msk hates this guy. He hates him. It was It was honestly impressive.
Here's Emir crying because of this Lucari. There's no way that's
not real. Is Emir gone live and cried because of the Lucari stuff?
>> Been a long time. >> That is today. Hold on. What?
There's no way. WHY DOES SHE CRY LIKE A CARTOON CHARACTER? I'm
actually I'm feeling the misogyny rise up. I'm I'm having misogyny
rise up right now because she cries like a cartoon character.
What is this? It's >> been a long time, >> dude.
What the is happening? This is because of Red Dead Redemption.
Okay. It wasn't because of Lucari.
The crying on stream from memory yesterday may be the reason
for what Lucari did on this his
Oh no, this isn't anything like that. This is a totally post.
I will say I'm enraged by it though. So, thank you. >> Yeah,
this is this is totally this is post. This is completely post.
Thank you for bringing to my attention that Emiru cries like
a robot. Thank you. I appreciate that. That is an important fact
to store in the back of my mind.
gun by
identify our face. >> Wait, some some dude in my Twitch
chat said your avatar look like a What the [__] do
you mean? This is a Nick Lee outfit. This is a Nicki special
and he dates he he married Amaranth. There's no way that guy's
a
Wait, what did Wait, hold on. Wait, hold on. Hold on. What did
Amaranth look like when when they first got married? Wait, wait.
Oh no.
Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. What did Amaranth look like
when they first got married? Oh, I can't find a picture. Hammeranth
tracer. She was a She was like a boy motor. Okay. She did not
She was like not a busty person or anything. She's just Isamaranth.
Oh, she did look like a little boy when they first got married.
[__]
>> Okay, hold on.
Next clip is all the way out here.
>> Roy is still streaming and trying to do damage control
instead of wiping his PC while the police are literally on the
way to his house. Bald
>> stopping the wipe, bro.
>> On my PC.
I get
it.
>> You must construct additional pylons
and you seek our need. Our pylon is under attack. You have not
enough
>> R/ Yeah, dude. I'm trying to find the the blurring thing.
It's not working. It's fine.
>> I started a whole stream when that part comes up.
>> Misfit made me. >> Dude, dude, this is the dumbest.
This Oh, I can't I can't say it enough how stupid it was to keep
streaming over this, man.
Thank you. The TTS during drama will never not be funny. It's
so funny. I don't He like let this happen to himself. He could
have easily avoided this. This is all avoidable for him. >> I
know.
>> Our pylon is under attack. >> Going to the next
time stamp. >> I don't know if you have realized this yet,
but in prison will be the lowly.
>> I don't know if you've realized this, but in prison,
you will be the lowly.
In prison, you will be the thing that is
>> Guys, there's nothing on this PC except for three TV
of random hens. A few notepad files. Probably some claps evasion
and definite. >> Oh, I just got to point this out real
>> Horrible void ray micro. They're just interceptors instead
of the actual carrier. Why are you just interceptors right now?
What are you doing here? >> Files. probably some tax evasion
and definitely not more incriminating material for him to go
to jail. >> Tax evasion. That's some Bosch stuff, man.
That's a Vosch reference right there. That's a voucher. >> I'll
repeat myself again. Better call
>> Enemy ships have set a course for our
>> We face the enemies.
We must >> This warrior awakens.
Base is under attack. >> Your power is greater than we
believed.
under attack. Base is under attack. >> I had to walk away
for a quick second. I hope you guys enjoyed reviewing his Starcraft
technique. Okay, we're on to the next time stamp now.
>> I think
it be the post post the torrent TTS. Did we get that? I didn't
hear it. >> So crazy.
>> Our pylon is under attack.
>> This is so crazy. I'm actually being attacked from every
direction.
>> Wait, that's awesome. No way. That's true in two ways.
It's I think he's commenting on the Starcraft right now, but
how do we know? How do we even know? Okay, he is being attacked
from every
>> Locking on target. Weak base is under
>> Dude, I think I'm Oh my god, bro.
>> That's true. again. I believe he's talking about the
Starcraft here, but you are. Yes, this is true. Do you think
that subconsciously he's like actually referring to the drama?
Yeah, I think I'm I think it's over, guys. We had a good run.
>> We meet the enemy in battle. This
>> our pylon is under attack.
>> There is a black market for bundling text file.
>> Dude, that knocking sound effect gets me every time.
>> Popular torrent to advertise things. People pay for
that service. Unfortunately, normies won't ever understand this.
If you can find the torrent and post it on Twitter, that may
>> It won't help because they weren't just advertising
something. No, nobody's taking out an ad. Nobody's going to go
pay someone. Hey, I really want to advertise this like link to
child. Can I Can I advertise this? Nobody's doing that, bro.
There ain't nobody doing that. I think online casinos do that.
Okay. No person on the entire internet is going, "Hey, I've got
this like link to niche child and I think I want to advertise
that somewhere."
Just post that link, guys. Post it. Hold on. >> This is
the next time staff.
>> It's the next time. >> You know, they got your
manestroyed. >> They got your mans on PDF charges. >> The
dude you'll be having with boy PDF
and he was your man. Zeroth 221.
He was your boy. Crystals charge speak. >> They got your
mans
Make your got your man if you're so >> They got your mans
on PDF charges >> online. You must construct additional
>> I I hate to say it. This may be the strongest argument
yet against weebs in general. Weebs, I'm sorry, but like this
may be the strongest argument that's ever existed against you.
is like this is the guy who's like, "Oh yeah, he jokes about
it, but like he's not doing anything real. It's not Dude, that
doesn't mean anything." And every time we get an insight into
one of these like
downloads, it just comes out the same way. Okay, move on. Okay,
anime is a gateway drug to
is a gateway drug to All right, you you slide down this pipeline
and everybody the whole way down that pipeline, they're like,
"No, no, no, no. That's not how it is. And then the FBI is at
your house. Okay.
I need you all to think deeply about this. Okay. No, it's fine.
No, it's fine. No, it's just their culture. No, it's fine. No,
it's fine. No, it's fine. Oh my god, the FBI is at my house.
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
EVERY SINGLE TIME. WAIT, it's replaced. I don't know. But I I
use it because it's more academic. >> This the enemy left
me.
>> Oh, what happened? We're good. We're good. We're good.
We're good.
Okay, we've got a big gap here.
I can't tell if nothing happens here, if he's just silent a lot
of the time or what's going on.
>> Tell me we didn't get this.
>> Okay, good.
We're good. Okay, we're good. We're good. We're good. We're good.
I need the
>> I need the timeline over here. Did I get
Nope, that's not it. I need I need my chapters back. God damn
it.
>> Why are my chapters not popping up now?
>> You know they got your madness.
>> Right here is where we were >> acting like >> Wait,
hold on. How do I Oh, here we go. >> Cracking jokes in
between splurging up. >> This is This is >> your
stream, dude. This isn't funny. This isn't a joke or something
you can laugh. I hope that this somehow was a mistake or a virus,
but it's looking real bad. You need to get help. I'm modding
myself.
>> Real real
real bad. >> And I'm associating with you. >> You're
not even my mod. You
stop the drama farmer. [__] you. >> Hold on.
>> Oh, this is bad.
>> There's so many zods.
Speaking of mods. Okay, speaking of mods at this point. Okay,
his mod just unmoded themselves and dipped.
Hold on. Let me open this. What is this screenshot? End your
stream. Dude, this is this is not this isn't funny. This isn't
a joke or something you can laugh off. I hope this is is somehow
was a mistake or a virus. Oh, people are just TTSing the actual
mod. Who is People are sending TTS of the actual mod. Oh, cool.
Very funny. This is the actual mod sending this. And then apparently
he unmods himself.
Uh rest of his mods are bases unbanning people and disabling
a mode only. Oh no, wait. Some of Is there a mod rebellion happening
in his chat as well at the same time that he's like banning people
who are bringing it up, but other mods are unbanning those people
and shifting it out of emote only and just continuing to wreck
this guy, ruin this guy's life? Is there a mod rebellion we're
unaware of? Amazing.
>> Mission's really hard,
>> dude. The mod rebellion's incredible.
>> Bulldog's here. >> Oh, Bulldog was there. I saw
Bulldog
have run out of Got any collection you could send?
Bulldog help.
I didn't do it, bro.
>> Bulldog's here, dude.
>> Hey, Balo. It's here. Yep. Miss me? No. Okay. 77777777777777777777777.
>> I feel like that's a bulldog donator who came in here.
I feel like No, I'm not skipping it. I feel like that's a bulldog
donator who is throwing up that donation. 77 77 77 77 77 77 77 77 77
77 77 77
maybe we give him a pass on this one because it's somebody with
actual but this character is very young as well, aren't they?
I feel like this character is like a everything but chest size.
Just saying777.
>> What is happening? Hold on. What is happening? What
is happening? What is happening? What is happening?
Stop tape coming. >> Well, I kind of have to. Let's restart
from the very beginning. That's 77
77 777 77 77 777 77 77 77 77 777 77 77 777 77 777
no mist 77 77 77 77 77 77 777
Desillian 777
Noillian 777
Octillian 777
Septilian 777
Sexilian 777
quintilian 777
quadrillion 777
trillion7 777
>> pedopile pedopile pedopile pedopile pedile pedile pedile
pedile pedile pedile pedile pedile pedile pedile pedile
pedile pedile pedile
>> hold on Hold on. Ain't no way he just gimm faced at
the Oh, hold on. Right
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. His eyes flick back up, don't
they? >> File. You hit our/ every Redditor in America is
going to wake up to the undeniable proof that you're a freak.
As vile as you,
>> dude. No way.
Uh after all that entire donation,
dude, I need lawyers.
>> And then it just goes back to silence for a little bit.
>> You have not enough minerals. >> Okay. Okay. Okay.
We're at 4 hours. 4 hours specifically.
>> The next time stamp is right here.
I get it now.
Knows he is absolutely cooked that not even Saul Goodman with
his $500,000
retainer can save him. It's why he is letting stream run to get
all the donos he can to pay for a lawyer. We'll get a fire body
cam footage of his >> Have set a course for our nexus.
>> Your power is greater.
>> Damn. Um it's a shame I cuz I used to watch this guy.
And is his channel still up? His channel is not up. He is temporarily
banned on Twitch somewhere between 1 and 14 days. We're not totally
sure yet. And it's a shame because I used to watch this guy.
That is a shame. Um, if you used to watch him, I feel like you
probably should have had some indicators that this was the case,
but hard to say. >> Then we believed FirstN
>> But you know what? You know what, Marob Thick,
welcome to the channel. Okay, turn over a new leaf here. We no
longer watch any stuff. We we just watch like normal. Okay, we're
a big we're a fan of the quo body type and not whatever this
guy actually wanted, you know, from that >> in his fallen.
What a thrilling sight. >> That's how this channel operates
now. >> If it is so thrilling, why not join us?
Well, I must save my strength to face Malash, of course.
>> Okay, no more no more space. >> Dude, just seeing
our tannis back in this is just a spoiler in and of itself. So
up, man.
Next, next lesson. Talk about forcing. >> The enemy shall
be purified. Chat, >> you want to talk about forcing? >> Tell
me your favorite thing about
Command me.
>> Enemy ships have set a course for our >> Why does
he think that's going to save >> Listening.
I command.
>> How would talking about a retired streamer save you?
Guide my
identify our
space is under attack. Your probes are under attack.
>> For retired I mean I assume I don't see
>> identify all
>> get cooked right now in the game
the game right now.
color guide awaiting instructions. Speak receiving.
Did that loose?
>> There we go. Okay.
>> Time stamp is coming up right now. >> All his
friends from his past appear in micro flashback before imminent
career
>> This guy is too dense and masochistic to suffer hell.
You'll enjoy it. >> The enemy.
>> That's probably true. I stand ready. Guide my blade.
>> I stand ready. Guide my blade.
>> Identify the enemies. >> Is that really it? I
thought he would comment more here.
>> Next next next time stamp's quite a ways away. You have
no time to enjoy
>> raise CTS to $5.
>> How much is force? How much is force in this CTS?
>> I stand.
>> Hey, he's busy with work stuff. WHAT HAPPENED TO LUCARI?
UH, he leaked a he leaked a notepad, a text file via notepad
that leads to like actual child actual material
and child abuse material, I should say. and he is coping through
it. Basically, it seems it seems possible that Lucari is looking
at, you know, if not outright like like little kids than like
15, 16, 17 year old stuff and he is
Yeah, it's just not great. Okay, it's not great. Lucari is cooked,
>> as they say. As the kids say, Lucari is cooked
$20.
>> Jesus.
Literally.
Listen, you've got shadow and light and I
>> Next time stamps a couple minutes away. It's right here.
>> Forward. We'll just see if it says anything else in
the middle here. I don't think so. I think the game >> focused
upon
>> focused up. Hold on. We got one here. >> Chance
to attack the guardian. >> Oh, holy, bro. channel the light
of your >> just talking about the game. Here's the >> Your
honor, it was Windows 11.
>> Base is under attack. >> Yeah, Lucari. Basically,
the link he had goes to some combination of
um Lollcon.
It's like all of the worst things that exist. That's where his
link goes that he leaked. Okay. It's rough, man. >> It's
rough. Any one of those things. Well, almost any one of those.
Any one of those things that's not explicitly illegal in like
every country. Cam uh might be defensible on its own. This guy
just wanted to watch like animals people. That's one thing. You
want to watch You want to watch a donkey a kid that you know
you're it's time for you to go. You got to go. You got to get
the [__] out of here. And there is the family news
thing which we've you know discussed a little bit here that this
seems to be when you have these family news links which are a
part of the pack that he was looking at. This seems to be a workaround,
a known workaround to find child specifically. Okay, so it's
a little more than just, you know, innuendo. It's a little more
than just nothing. It's not nothing. It is something. This is
tangible. This is real. And he should have gone offline and responded
to it, but he has decided to go to stay live to stream through
it. And it's probably the worst decision for him. But at the
same time, um, no, that's not legal. Koser the Oh, wait. No,
this is actually yeah, a legal workaround that like apparently
if you have like you know how people sometimes have like pictures
of their kids when they're like toddlers and they're like naked,
they're like giving them a bath or something. Oh, it's my baby's
first bath. I think it's some loophole like that that's supposed
to make it so that's not LWD. But even I think there's like a
lot of the child laws have like a ludy thing where it's like
intended to
and so people will look up stuff where it's not intended to be
lude. Like it's a family it's a family event. It's a family thing.
It's like a photo album. They'll look up stuff like that to get
around the law cuz that won't be illegal to hold for whatever
reason or view.
Let's stop talking about it. No, I don't think we have to stop
talking about it. It's gross. But you should probably know that
there are people out here who use these loopholes to get around
things. >> Not at all.
>> Your probes are under attack.
>> Yo, this mission is really trustful, dude. Holy.
We are at full power.
>> Um, sorry I have to Google this because I can hardly
believe this is actually happening. Not that I don't trust you,
Nikur. If you want, go to the beginning of the kickstream. All
right? Or the Twitch stream, but the kickstream more preferably.
kick.com/jstk.
Head over there and watch me explain it right off the bat. I
explain it perfectly. Like why this is weird, why this is bad,
what the links are going to, all that. I read some of the file
>> Oh god.
Oh god. Oh, what is this next one? Classic zero micro bro. Do
you see how much is on the screen, man? What do you want me to
do about this? >> Get off. >> I'm like being attacked
from all sides. >> Crystals charged. >> True. Yes.
Yes. You're being attacked by from all sides. Everybody's Everybody's
got you, man.
>> 5K gas. >> YEAH. 5K GAS. HUNTER MINERALS.
>> I mean, pretty objectively, you got a lot of air units
over here. Can you not build high templar at this point? Make
archons. You got a lot of gas. That's what you should be building.
That's what you should be prioritizing.
>> Fog is fading. >> Maybe he can't make them. >> Better
time is there to slay my enemies.
>> Just saying. Just saying, man. >> You're at full
power. >> Restart from the very beginning,
>> man. I'm like, I'm tired. Like, holy, I'm tired.
>> He's very tired. He's very EP, guys. >> So tired.
>> We reached EP times
>> now. At some point, he will get baited. He's We're about
T minus 15 minutes from him getting baited into really litigating
this. Okay, >> so we're going to keep watching.
About a minute and a half from here. We got another time stamp.
>> You know what's crazy?
is legal to own and consume in every state in the USA. What's
even crazier is that it's legal to produce in three states in
the USA and it's legal to make in Russia and Japan, too. But
that's far less surprising.
>> Shadow the light. >> How do you know? >> I
mean, Japan's not surprising.
>> Russia a little surprising. >> Must construct
additional pylons. >> Oh, does he not want to comment on
that at all?
>> you want to talk? [__] I'm innocent, bro.
Don't look at those. You're not going to believe that, though.
But I don't care.
>> He's innocent, dude. He's innocent. He's totally innocent.
Nothing wrong. Nothing happening. Nothing crazy.
>> This vessel shall >> The guardians stand watch
over the
them slowly
and painfully.
>> Ch innocent drama screwed up. Even when we are fighting
for you. >> Chat doesn't care if you're innocent or >> Establish
our defense. >> They just want to stir and they see an
opportunity to stir [__] so they're going to do it.
>> Shadow the light of May.
>> Nobody in my chat could possibly care about my child
port, guys. Nobody Nobody in chat could possibly care about that.
>> They don't care about anything else. >> I don't
know if that's true, man. I I don't know about that. Okay,
>> guys. If you're watching right now,
>> if you're watching, you're enjoying the content, I need
you to go to
go to the stream chat channel and give me links of reactions
that we want to watch. Okay, I've got the Asmin Gold reaction.
I've got the soda popping reaction. Okay, any other reactions?
I'm looking for reactions now. Let's let's go through all of
the reactions to this because I want to get it all together at
the same time. Okay, head over to
Hop in the Discord. Be a part of the community. It's a big drama
community. Every time something like this pops off, we're live.
All right, we're covering it. mother ships in this region. They
are carrying shipments of solarite.
>> Uh, how are you him in this situation? And you don't
just end and never stream again. Um, well, I don't know how he
didn't end when he leaked it and just like go and figure out
what you're doing. Especially like maybe after 30 minutes when
people are like going hard on him. Just go, "Oh, guys, I don't
know, dude. This is people are going crazy. I got to go figure
out what's going on." And then you like log off and you go and
figure out a statement you're going to make. Instead, he just
made multiple conflicting statements. Not not >> I don't
think all alarak would mind if we troll by his chat the whole
time. >> Okay, hold on. >> What's going on next?
Oh, hold on. You see that? Oh, interesting.
He He wants us to believe
What? What is he doing? He just put something up at OBS. He doesn't
want us to see his face right now.
>> What? That's so weird. Why did he Oh, wait. Hold on.
That's not OBS. That's his um Wait, that's his uh that's his
donations or whatever. They probably randomly place it and put
it over his >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They randomly place put
it over his face.
>> He [__] up
>> Oh, whoops. Lost my chapters. Need my chapters.
Here we go. Here we go. 422.
Clearing it up. >> Got to clear this up, bro. I've already
I don't know like what else I can do. I've already explained
everything. under >> Pop open the notes. I'm trying to
see
>> Show proof. Wait, what? How?
>> How? How do I show proof? Certainly your chat will give
you the way to show proof. They won't just try to [__]
you over. Certainly your chat will be the ones you want to listen
to, right? Certainly your chat are totally down to show you proof.
The time stamp is 437 Maximus. I got it.
>> Okay, hold on. We're going 425.
>> just ignore it.
>> She's not going to stop. Is what it is.
>> Did it stop?
Annihilation commencing.
Shadow the life of the site were you gooning on your sangu complex.
>> You going to answer that or no? Just read it and then
>> the parene are gone. >> For those who don't believe
>> is legal. As of June 2021, only Hawaii, New Mexico,
West Virginia, and Wyoming did not have laws against bestiality.
But far more insane is that possessing pizzu in Russia is disgustingly
completely legal. >> No lying.
>> Prismatic core online. >> Tdderine ships are heading
towards our nexus hierarch. >> Glad glad.
>> Let me make that [__] $20. Hold on. >> Oh,
HE'S GOING TO OH, we're up the We're up in the TTS to 20 bucks.
Let's go. One too many awkward questions asked. Okay, >> don't
do that, guys. Don't Don't ask this guy awkward questions. >> How
do I How do I increase donate? Let me see. How the [__]
do I do this? >> God, I'm going to I'm going to end up
ordering food again. I have food I could make and I'm going to
end up ordering food cuz I am literally just trying to get content
out for you guys.
Guys, donate. Donate right now. If you're on Twitch, primers
would be good. If you're on kick, you know, sub, throw in kicks,
okay? Buy kicks on kick. Buy kicks on the kick platform. Give
me kicks, okay? I love kicks more than anything else. Kicks are
the best way to donate. If you guys want to donate, kicks are
the best way. kick.com/jdk.
Head over there. All right, the kickstream is far more,
you know, where it's at. Give me one second. I need to order
food because I haven't eaten anything and we got content to make.
Hey, food is ordered. Food is ordered. We're good to go. Let's
>> Haven't done this in a while. >> Okay, 20 bucks
for TTS. He hasn't done this in a while. Uh-huh. Now he's silent
here for a quick second. We're going to go forward. Does >> anyone
know where this talks? Getting ready for when this pops up a
little bit later. Okay. Put this guy back down >> Oh, here
we go. Tipping settings. I found it. >> [__]
is this image? This image is so that we could go through the
next part without, you know, sharing that link. I'm going to
have to cover the screen for about 10 minutes of this VOD cuz
for about 10 minutes of this VOD, he's going to be pulling up
that link again, which he's like a so
>> you know boys win. Farm the lawyer fees >> Mandatory
minimum 2 to 10 years. 10k fine on one count. Two counts is 20
years. Three counts is 99 years. He's >> Ah, I think he
just did this event with these cosplayers, Morpai and a couple
other girls. Dude, this guy was in Gooner. This guy was in Gooner
Heaven. All he had to do is not leak this. He was in Gooner Heaven.
He got collabs with all of the like Goonaxing
female streamers cuz I'm sure his audience is just all like massive
Only Fan simps.
He got He got collabs with all of them. Whatever he wanted. He
was in Goar heaven. Goar paradise. >> Wait, someone keeps
saying text. Wait, why? Why do you want me to go text file recent?
Go to notepad file recent. Why? >> Uh probably they want
to see what you've opened recently.
Recent. And they want to see what all of
>> Dude, he's doing this all. >> This is worse than
Hassan, but it's the same thing where Hassan like keeps
and if you're going to stay live, you're people are going to
expect you to go and look through things. He doesn't want to
look at his recent files for obvious reasons,
right? So, he's waiting and checking it all off of stream. He's
checking it all with everything like
Of course, nobody's going to believe you, bro. What are you doing?
>> Help me prove my innocence somehow.
>> If I do it,
>> you check LSF, >> bro. I don't want to read the
LSF hate threads, man. There's I know what I already know what
they're saying. >> Oh, no. >> Just cleared it. I
didn't clear it, >> dude. Okay.
>> Lost a notepad. Yeah, I literally did.
>> You literally lost a notepad.
Why you have that on a computer? It was I downloaded without
my permission. >> It downloaded without his permission.
>> I literally had no idea what the it was
>> and then I deleted it. >> Will you believe him,
chat? >> Once I figured out what it was, >> but when
you delete like texts and
No, it just doesn't I guess it just opens up whatever the was
open even if even if it's deleted.
I don't >> I that's not what it would have happened here.
He could make this believable if he'd left Notepad open, but
he says, "Oh, if I reopen Notepad, then it opens up everything."
this drama is a good ad for any password manager secret notes
feature. Is it really though? Like he if he pulls it up on stream,
he's still just, isn't he? Like, he just didn't have to pull
this up on stream. He just pulled up something on stream that
gives it away. I don't think this help I don't think anything
helps him here. I really don't.
Anyway, bro, >> keep going. He's just a >> Stop saying
that. It's the truth.
>> Is it though? Okay, we're like five minutes away. >> Test
it live for everyone. Show >> right here. >> Show
us how it stays even after
>> Guess we can test it. >> Oh wow. I guess we could
test it, guys.
Okay. So, he's from here. I I'm going to put this up. If anything
pops up that you guys need to see, I will let you know. But for
now, I'm going to assume that this Aiden the Aiden Carl Marks
image will save us. Also, I don't have a small enough resolution
size to cause the blurring effect. So, I'm going to I'm going
to cover this. Okay, we're going forward forward. Forward
>> recent. What is this?
>> He's not showing anything. You guys can see that he's
hasn't even pulled up his desktop yet. You'll see on the edges
of the video that he'll pull up his desktop
>> Let me read this >> when this pops up. Okay.
How does
a list?
>> He's just opening up some browser. >> Let's see.
Show the date when it was
>> here. Hold. Here we go. Hold on. Hold on. He does ask
>> while he's open recently. Does it show the date when
it was opened or like all this hesitance
all of this hesitance open? He's not opened up anything yet.
How do I explain this? I think it feels like it's almost as if
Lucari is like not he he
he's getting so because I think he's got some other [__]
going on. He's checking off screen. No, he's got his he's got
this up on screen right now. He says notepad, but he's not clicking
anything which makes me think he knows he knows he's guilty.
He knows he's got some he's scared to click the file recent thing
right now. He's like actively terrified of looking at this. Who
that? Dickers, thank you for the Thank you for the raid, Dickers.
appreciate it. We're still going through the Lucari stuff. We
are just getting to the point where he pulls up the link on his
stream another time. >> No, this is going to help me.
Is there a chance that it it helps me?
>> I can see his face. >> No, not really.
No, there's not really a chance it helps you at all. I don't
think this helps you
>> It only shows a list of recently opened text files.
>> Hold on. Did I put the Aiden image back up? I did. Okay.
I just I need to make sure that Aiden image is still there. Still
protecting us from all evil. Okay.
>> Protecting us from everything.
Okay. He's clicked file. Oh no. He was about to click file. He
moved away. >> And to be honest, the wait is already >> over.
It's absolutely over. Moyes just dropped a video on him. Oh no.
Lucari.
Oh no. Oh no. I will say, although I don't think it's relevant
here, I do think he's like guilty, which is why I'm like not
doing any nuance here. There could be situations like this where
there's some nuance and I I think he would be cooked anyway.
I think there's just no way for any modern like influencer who's
big to go and say like, "Oh, I want you to show nuance on this
like thing." He'd be in any case. Okay, I do think he's actually
here justifiably. He lied so many times. It's like it's super
suspicious,
but man, he he would be [__] here no matter what.
>> As soon as he lied about like deleting the file
and like how that works, I was like, "Oh,
>> as soon as he started lying about it, I was like, "Oh,
this guy's cooked. This guy's done."
ask you even if you prove your >> That's true. >> Well,
at least we'll have something we can say. >> Okay, we're
skipping forward. Skipping
>> Okay, he's just mouse down to reset. He is like holding
it over open. Recent recent is
um all a couple links inside.txt is the one he had.
Bap for fun. Readme.txt.
What is this?
Hold on. Hold on. Okay, I still have this all blocked. Good.
Readme_g.txt.
Dude, he's going to get cooked by these other things as well.
The the the ones that are very noticeable, the ones that are
very important, I think, are all couples links inside.txt txt
and fap for fun. Readme.txt
then readme eg.txt.
What's readme eg? Bro, are we going to catch him? Hold on. What's
readme eg? Cuz I do think if that means eirls, could we catch
him on some atriarch? Will that even matter if we catch him on
some What if he's on some, you know, niche
some niche AI deep fake site and he's pulling up all the egirl?
Sounds like he did download them. Well, people are saying it
sounds like these things are from torrent that he's downloaded,
right? They're readmes for torrent. They sound like readmes for
torrent or archive files in some way. I don't know. Keep listening.
>> Okay. What does this mean? >> All couples.com.
>> Fat for fun is uh
>> site. You also visit fat for fun. >> I download
a lot of that.
Okay. That's literally Is that not the file with the sus in it?
Like
>> does he have anything? So
>> does he understand how badly he's contradicting himself
here? Hold on. >> donated $3. This I got a virus and my
pants fell down.
>> This is actually what's happening. So for one of these
files, he got a virus and then he opened it. And then the other
ones that are in the exact same vein, he just opened those cuz
he jumped off on those websites.
You understand how badly he's himself over right now, right?
So like in one of these in one of these cases he's going actually
you know I off to this website all the time this fap for fun
website but also it's mixed in with this other website that's
got
cheese pizza on it. Okay
you saying dog the you saying? >> It says one thing but
it has a bunch of sus in it.
>> Hold on. I'm going to let you guys see his face. It's
still playing by the Okay, he's just >> I don't I don't
Dude, I don't understand. Like, >> there's a round where
he opens up the file, but I I I'm just being super careful about
not playing this on screen. Okay, we can't watch it on
>> I'll describe it to you. >> You're acting. >> You're
right. I I literally showed them and there's still like >> It
is kind of like It won't open if it's deleted. Okay. Well, I
100% deleted it, so it shouldn't
file. Open recent.
And he opens all couples. Oh.
But it's deleted. >> I just skipped forward. Oh, hold on.
The YouTube video got updated. So, it did open. But the YouTube
video got updated. I don't think the the link to the new thing
is in here at all. I think um I think the person who uploaded
this for me deleted it from the video.
>> Okay. I just I think I can move this away. I think we're
good. I don't know that we're good. >> You tried it.
>> Oh, no way, dude. No shot, >> dude. I deleted
this. Oh.
>> So, basically >> what happened was,
>> and it does cut perfectly. Hold on. I'll show you guys
exactly what he does. He opens it up. >> Open, right?
>> Open resets and and
>> and he opens it and it pops up again. As in he literally
went and opened it, it reopened. As in he still has the file
there somewhere. The file he said he definitely deleted just
opened up immediately and he did that to himself on his stream.
>> Did you lie?
>> Dude. Dude. Dude. What? What's your boy >> Tried
it. >> What's he doing here? >> Dude text. I deleted
this. Can I like go >> test with another file?
>> So he had some excuse again. If he just logged off.
If he had just logged off, he could have been he would never
have had this happen. But now he's like quite literally lied.
He has quite literally gone and said, "Guys, I deleted this file.
It was like a vir I I knew it was bad. It auto downloaded. I
deleted it. I deleted it." Then he goes to open it and it opens
up immediately.
Bro, what are you doing?
Oh no.
>> usually when people say this statement, Private Huff,
it's never been more over. It's like an exaggeration.
But I actually can't think of a time in my entire memory of covering
drama on the internet where it's been more over than it is now.
Like it's literally this is up there with this is like the same
thing as Destiny doxing the minor that he was with, right? Um
or the minor that was the identity that of the 30-year-old man
he was with. I I can't remember exactly how that goes, but like
it's on that level of like self harm, like just totally unforced
error. Nobody made you do this. Nobody made you try this. But
you did it anyway. Just for our
>> bro. Dude, can I like open file location or something?
>> No, I don't trust this.
Can I open file location or something? Sorry, we got to we got
to test this out one more time.
Open file location or something. I don't want you to do that.
Where we at? 4 39
>> I deleted that. I don't understand.
I skip forward a little bit. Like, what the [__]
So, he opens File Explorer here and realizes he still has the
file. Okay, moving this away again. Don't me over, Lucari. Do
not show it now. I do believe we're past the point where it will
be shown on stream. Don't [__] me over, Lucari. Don't
you do it. Don't you do it. He's just chilling. He's just chilling
the whole time. >> Oh my god. >> Not really talking
anymore. Like, at what point do you just go, I just I thought
I swear to God, I thought I deleted it. I don't know what the
what the [__] up with that,
>> guys. I guess it was just still there. I don't know.
I don't know how that happened, guys. How did that happen? >> But
I mean, you see like the text document doesn't seem like it's
bad, right? But then like there's like bad in >> Yes. This
is the guy from the pirate software drama. Yep. >> Everyone
already knew you were a DJ. I am a DJ.
>> This is the guy from the pirate software drama. Shouldn't
have taken my hypnotic dagger, bud. Shouldn't have taken my hypnotic
dagger, dude.
You weren't even a level. You couldn't even use it at the level
you were at. It was really stupid for you to take that dagger.
I can actually use it now. You could keep running Scarlet Monastery.
And uh it's just way more efficient for me to get it actually.
Yep. It's just way more efficient for me to get it.
Okay, dude. Okay, dude. Yes, >> but not like that. >> Same
guy.
>> I don't know. Oh well. I'm sorry, guys.
>> Dude, they just keep spamming the same emote. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I still had to file, guys. I'm sorry. Imagine
if Pirate Software goes live for a RIP Bozo Lucari stream. Um,
that would be incredibly funny. I don't think you could do it,
but that would be incredibly funny.
Open recycling bin. I mean, I clear my recycling bin all the
time.
So, I was recently trying to find space on my PC to download
ad games or ad sponsor stuff.
I feel like there's something now. >> No idea.
>> I chat. I don't understand how any of this [__]
works. >> I don't understand how any of it works. >> Fap
for fun and put the links but not the other two. Wait, what do
you mean create the FAP for fun? I didn't create it. Fap for
Okay, fap for fun is like you download a game. It comes in a
zip and then you open up the zip and it's the text document inside
the zip
and it explains like the the game that that's fat for fun.
There's like bunch of different hintai games you can download
and there's like a whole thing like translated and [__]
Dude, this guy is so cooked. I do think there's a small chance
that he just downloaded whatever random zips from this site cuz
he was off and he downloaded like some
and and it did include like this text file that he opened and
was like, "Oh, that's not it." And he didn't even think about
it. But he has lied so badly. He's like tried to cover his tracks
so badly through this whole thing that he's just [__]
now. He's like destroyed himself by staying alive. I I believe
that it's possible. I don't think it happened in this case, but
I believe it's possible.
Don't forget if he had two files, if he only deleted one. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I understand that he's probably he's looking for
stuff adjacent to this. I'm saying for this specific one, it's
possible. I just don't believe him.
>> I'm trying to be as honest with you guys as possible.
Like like I'm trying to literally trying to be as honest with
you guys as possible. It's like that [__] just comes
with like the zip file. >> Show download history is not
going to like download history is not going to do. I use incognito.
>> Why? I use incognito. So, there's not there's literally
nothing here.
>> Trust me, I'm trying.
I'm answering your
>> Give me one second. We got a lot of him crashing out
still to go. So, give me a second. I'll be right back. I just
got to use bathroom real quick. >> Cleared it. Okay. Well,
it says yesterday literally. So, I didn't clear it recently,
obviously, cuz if I hit clear, this wouldn't be here. Can you
please remove all the league mods and VIPs? No. Since you're
on Sans's Wi-Fi, he can request your search history from your
provider. I mean, sure, he can. Like, honestly, honest to God,
he can. He wants to have the right to remain silent.
IRL stream your arrest. Not getting arrested. Be fine. I don't
have this on my PC, bro. I'm good. Unless it's illegal to have
like on your PC, then I'm done. But
>> if I mean the kind of >> the kind of he's got
might actually be illegal in the state of Texas. In fact, I think
that is where we go next. I think the next part of this is when
he starts looking up what the law is around in Texas.
>> Otherwise, no, >> you'll be fine. Techone. Wait.
Teone >> wait having >> this is all coming for teto
as well. >> PC is illegal in Texas. Wait, are you >> Not
necessarily. If you have anime girls in your that look like the
girls you bring up on your stream, like the girls you were playing
this video game with not too long ago. Hold on. Where's that
video game? Oh, I've got too many tabs open. Hold on. If you
got girls who look like Dawn, that's actually where we'll go.
If you got girls that look like your wife Dawn, all right,
then you're that you're quite the state of Texas. You're in trouble,
buddy. Ain't no getting away from it. >> I don't have him
on my PC. Never minding. Forget what I said. What? >> Oh,
yeah. If you've got If you've got girls in your head that look
like these girls from the game you're playing here >> with
with counter arguments like >> Oh, sorry. The video you're
watching
>> You got girls who look like this in your head. You are,
buddy. It's over for you. >> What the? Wait, really? When
you guys
>> it's not chat is baiting. Oh my god, dude. I was actually
scared for a second. WAIT, ARE YOU GUYS WAIT, NO. WAIT, SERIOUSLY?
I Dude, no. Hold on. I got to look this up.
Is
having
on your hard drive ILLEGAL IN TEXAS? WHAT? I I TYPED IN and it's
like bring up dude, what the like
why is like all of a sudden like connected to this now? Is it
2020 [__] or what? Dude, I typed is he illegal and
it like this like I'm like I typed bro what >> I It's very
funny. It's very ironic that he can't see this is like the example.
You are the example Lucari of why these things are connected.
In fact like you are in fact the perfect example of why these
things have become connected. It seems like the cut a weeb and
a bleeds moniker that that saying it seems like it just continues
to be true.
It's like, you know, you either die the hero, live long enough
to see yourself become the villain. Either you die an anime fan
or you live long enough to see yourself become a It seems like
that.
I And I say that as somebody who is a huge anime fan, okay, and
turned away. I had to turn away from anime. I I had to turn away
because I saw where it was taking other people and I just couldn't
do it anymore. I'm not That's not even entirely true, but like
it's mostly true at this point. and I don't watch anime anymore
cuz I dude it just seems like there's a lot of things connected
there and I'm sitting there on my own side. I'm like
I want to be the guy who's like no I'm the different anime watcher.
I'm totally different from everybody else. I I couldn't possibly
No, man. I'm seeing a lot of other people fall into this trap
and I'm like you know what? Maybe I should go THE OTHER WAY.
>> NO, THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE BECAUSE I USE INCOGNITO.
OKAY. Oh my [__] god.
It didn't even tell me if it was or not. For anybody watching
on Twitch, really quickly before I comment on that, for everybody
watching on Twitch, okay,
if you do want to get in the chat that's actually moving, we
have about I think 500 450 people on Twitch right or sorry on
kick right now and the chat moves significantly faster. That's
where most of the community is. I could just show you like literally
for anybody typing in Twitch chat, you guys are not on the screen.
Oh, hold on. You guys are basically like not on the screen at
all.
There's like a whole bunch of Twitch. I can just have that. It's
like just mostly kick icons. Okay, Twitch chatters barely type.
>> If you guys do want to head over, be in the rest of
the community. >> All right, head over to kick.com/jok.
Thank you very much for watching on Twitch though. Appreciate
you, >> MAN. JUST WHAT DO YOU MEAN, BRO?
>> YEAH, link it. Link it. Link it. OR LIKE I CAN'T TELL
IF YOU GUYS ARE trolling me or not. >> You're really innocent.
Go to command line ipconfig/disdns.
What the I don't know what that's going to do, bro. You're scaring
me.
You got a rogue mod disabling followers mode. Bro, I have too
many mods. I don't know who's doing that. If I mod it, the mod
the modari's
chat is hilarious. >> I'll have to figure out who it is
later. >> So, Lucari was trying to like ban people who
were bringing it up and then go mode only mode so he wasn't getting
trolled. Some of his mods were trying to do that and then other
mods came along and said, "No, no, no, no, no, no. Let's get
to the bottom of this.
Back to text mode. Back to out of followers only. Back to text
mode. Let anybody ask a question. Can I get VIP to be ready for
the comeback stream? Bro, I'm gonna be streaming tomorrow. As
long as I can stream, I'll I'll be streaming.
>> All right. You know, hold on. Let me go over to Best
Friend's Twitter. I feel like he's not going to be able to stream
tomorrow, it turns out.
Let me look. Let me look. Let me look. Let me look. Um, this
is the Where's the There's the kickban. Came out five hours ago.
Twitch ban came out five hours ago. Temporary ban on Twitch,
though. Temporary ban. Okay. Not going to be able to stream on
Twitch, it turns out. He's not He's not heading anywhere except
maybe YouTube if he's got a YouTube, but I'm guessing that won't
last long if he goes live
>> If I can't stream, I apologize.
>> Address me with the elephants. Oh boy. >> The
only way for that to showc Doc is inviting you, Lucari. >> Show
up as if show up is you searching it up before. It brings you
to a link or something you've searched before.
That literally doesn't make any sense,
Yeah, I'm not Lucari. I'm My skin tone is much darker than >> because
I don't search that >> just to be clear on the records.
>> Lucari's banned. Lucari is banned. Yes, Lucari was banned.
>> Can you scan your PC for the word? Wait, why do we have
an emergency meeting? Age isn't the issue. It's
>> This guy is >> stream but IRL, I guess.
>> No, but seriously, is legal in Texas? Like to have on
your PC? Cuz if if it is, I have to delete it. No, it's fine.
Okay. Ask Grock.
>> You know what, Grock?
Oh, this is not good. This is not good. We're going to we're
going to pull up the moist video, guys, in just a little bit.
Okay, we're going to finish the VOD. We've got
about 30 minutes left in this VOD. 25 minutes left and then we'll
go to the Moisty video. We'll go to more reactions from around
the streamer reverse. All right, stay tuned here.
and kick.comjsd.
All right. Welcome, welcome, welcome everybody. >> Thought
you said you have no hints on a PC. Oh, it's on my hard drive.
My external hard drive. >> Dude,
he's doing the thing. He's doing the I don't have that stuff
on my computer. I don't have that stuff uh on my computer. It's
not on my It's not Listen, I would never retain
on my hard drive.
Why do you say it like that? Why you got to keep Why do you keep
saying it like that, dude? He's a little weird.
You're weird. You're a weirdo. >> Ask yourself this. Have
you ever seen Lucari and Force Online at the same time? The answer
is no. They play the same games except for Gotcha. Anime links
is the only links for refuses to skip. Lucari's forces YouTuber
Persona.
>> Okay, we're looking for when he actually finally get
on your PC in Texas illegal rock.
going to talk about almost certainly
and that's if they think it's like >> keep it clearly adult.
You're almost certainly fine for private possession.
>> Do we believe he keeps it clearly adult here guys?
>> Are we believing in his ability to keep
>> are we believing in Lucari here to keep it clearly adults?
you explain yourself why like hey Lucari I didn't like what you
said there like what Nick did >> I don't know if we believe
in him okay >> you're not gonna piss me off
>> it's when you're like you dumbass [__]
>> I'm sorry I'm sorry
it's just bizarre it's bizarre stuff okay
very strange very very very strange
back to back to the VOD right here oh my [__]
loves this clip because That illustrates what I'm talking about
very
>> Bro, it's not worth it. Just [__] delete
my hard drive.
>> Dude, is he not just straight up Is he not just straight
up confessing to having a bunch of on his computer,
dude? It's not worth it. It's not worth it. I'll just delete
my hard drive, bro.
Bruh. My guy. My guy.
>> My dude. >> Uh
trying to hide evidence on stream. I mean, what if you don't
want to what if you don't want it anymore? I don't think I have
anything to go. Okay, so the only thing I'm like, the only thing
I'm worried about here is like cuz like anime girls
like some people might look at anime girl be like that girl is
a like 18 plus. That girl is not like there's a that's a fine
line, man. >> It's not worth it, guys. It's not worth it.
Some people look at these girls and they go, "Yeah, that's 18
plus."
Dude, I wish somebody had asked. I don't know who these girls
are, what anime they're from, but I do wish somebody would ask,
"Are these girls 18 plus?" Do you have Do you have these characters
on your computer, Lukari? Have you ever
these characters on your computer? Be honest.
The answer to that is yes. And nobody's even really questioning
it. Okay, every everybody here understands the answer to that
question is yes. Come on, man. He doesn't have it on his >> Cuz
like some people were like, "Oh, man. The girl doesn't have like
triple D and
a fat ass. Okay, they're they're like that's what I'm worried
about.
>> Title. Okay. Oh, I just see I just saw take your lumps
in his chat. Hold on. No,
hold on. >> Where is he? >> Not him either. >> Looking
for him. Right there. Oh, god damn it, dude. His chat's moving
fast. No. JTO chatter. Take your lumps right there. Is take your
lumps here now? I don't know. >> Okay. Honestly, IF THE
TEXT TITLE HAD THAT [__] in it, then sure. BUT LIKE
THE TEXT TITLE DOESN'T EVEN HAVE THE What the [__]
He's He's appealing to the ambiguity of the file name.
I don't think that's happening, man. I don't think this I don't
think this helping. I don't think that's happening for you. Cannot
appeal to the file name. No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
>> Explain no. You know, it's the JBT.
>> WHY DID HE READ THAT? WHY DID HE READ THAT? WHY DID
HE READ THAT, CHAT? Explain the JBT. This is in the tabs. Okay.
This uh this JBT. What is this? It's obviously that's what it
means. Will Lucari be truthful? Will he be honest right now?
But what >> was recent? Cuz it was immediately deleted.
Immediately knew that [__] was
>> Okay. How do you keep downloading these things and finding
them? How do you find them? How do you download? >> But
the other one came back or some I god I deleted it all. I don't
know how like what the that is pretty bad when he's like dude
all couple links all couple links how am I supposed to know from
the file name the other file name 500 video files
how is I supposed to know HOW WAS I SUPPOSED TO know
deleting deleting evidence
dude I'm pretty sure they could just like can't they just like
bring it back or whatever
>> deleting like deleting it doesn't do anything just bring
back, right?
Like there's actually no way to get
>> This is actually a very important point in like
I get
there's like one subsection that I would allow some streamer
to if you're like trying to with somebody and you're recording
a video via your streaming computer because that's where you
have like the good camera. I would maybe allow for like that.
I think I've heard of like instances that's what happened to
the one um that's what happened to the Slay the Spire streamer.
I think he was like recording a video for his wife or he's like
his wife and he's like recording it v OBS and he went live. I
think that's one of the cases. It's like maybe every other case
of you doing on your main computer like actually off. You're
a loser. You you know what you're doing. You know what you're
risking. Everybody's got a laptop now. Everybody's got a phone.
Go use the other device that isn't connected to your professional
job to goon. How hard is that that you like have to goon at your
main workstation?
brother, just
grow up. Grow the up, man. >> Doesn't do anything. You
just bring it back, right?
Like, there's actually no way to get get rid of it completely.
Should you talk to a lawyer and Bisk >> on like this computer,
by the way, on my streaming computer, I don't have like a dual
streaming setup or duke PC streaming setup, but I do like on
my streaming computer, I've never like entered my own credit
card details into this computer. I've never entered any of my
private information cuz I never want that like associated to
the stream stuff. You know what I'm saying? So, I don't enter
my address. I don't enter my private information. I just like
I only log into stuff and use different
Yeah. If I can do it, Lucari can do it. Okay. Next time for notepad
files. If yes, you have a virus. Okay.
It's actually a good point. Let me try that. >> Oh, hold
on. Hold on. Is that That's No way. Wait. I'm sorry. Aiden's
coming back, guys. Aiden's coming back to say
>> LISTEN, CHRIS HANSEN, COME ON IN.
>> FBI, OPEN UP. >> Cannot find. Okay. >> Oh,
boy. Oh, no. Lucari.
So, he goes to his recents and he clicks ON IT.
>> FBI, OPEN UP. >> And now cannot find all couples
links inside. TXT file.
Now he's cooked cuz now he's shown that he didn't delete it before.
He definitely didn't delete it before. It is deletable. He didn't
delete it before.
Oh boy. Oh boy. What is that? >> Cannot find. Okay, it's
gone.
Bro. Bro. Bro.
>> No, it's not a bait. I mean, it's true. >> I now
I don't know for the rest of the stream. I don't even know what
else is going on here. >> Cari situation is crazy.
Situation. Yo, Nyx, what up? >> What? What situation, guys?
I wonder I wonder what situation we could possibly be referring
to. Lucari
the pay to view those fouls. If you show that you didn't spend
money on it, you're good. Yeah, I didn't.
>> Wait, what? What terrible advice is that? Uh if you
just show you didn't spend any money on this child, you're fine.
Uh, that's an insane loophole that nobody would possibly accept
ever and none of the laws even talk about spending money on it.
I don't What the [__] was that? What the [__]
was that [__] excuse? >> Okay, then yeah, we're
good. Then we're [__] then we're actually good. If
that's the case, we're actually good cuz I didn't spend any money
on that. >> Wait, were you not actually good before?
Were you
What? Wait, what?
Dude.
Dude, wait.
Were you not actually good before?
>> I literally immediately deleted it. >> Bro, that's
free trial. How is free trial? I'm off the hook. I'm off the
hook, boys. >> You can check my bank and everything. People
want >> I felt I felt lowkey bad. I Sorry. I lowkey felt
bad hating on this guy in the past because I thought he had a
learning disability, but now I feel vindicated.
O, very rude. Very rude. >> Elsa for accessing the files
inside.
Okay. Well, like how then? Some people were saying you have to
pay for it. Some people were saying don't.
>> Can someone send me the screenshots of the LSF comments?
If somebody could find the LSF comments really quickly. There's
one more detailed one. So, we pulled up one of them on stream,
which is the one talking about the like family nudity stuff,
which does seem to be sort of a loophole for child viewers, people
who are trying to find child. There's another one who goes through
and explicitly says, "Yeah, I clicked through the end of these
links. Yes, there are like naked or abused children in some of
these links. There's a white hat who decides to take the burden
on themselves and describe what is in the actual links. That
could be a lie. I cannot verify it. But there is like a a white
hat who decided to go and look this stuff up for us. Even though
all of us were all like, "No, I'm not clicking on it. I'm not
doing it." There was some white hat martyr who decided to click
these links for the rest of us. Okay. So we never have to. I'd
like to see that. Like what is it? They weren't. Are they?
You like pineapple and pizza? I don't. Oh, no. I just read the
comments saying what was inside. I'm not clicking on that. Yeah,
you shouldn't. Honestly, you guys shouldn't click on that [__]
>> Yeah, probably not. Here, one sec. My food just got
delivered. I'm grabbing it real quick. >> Leave it to Lucari.
Scan your PC for viruses.
Oh, what
what what program should I use for that? Malware bites. Should
we download this [__] No.
>> We're still doing the virus cope, eh?
this like hilarious virus that just injects random child links
into your >> I feel like I haven't used this in the
>> is that that's what we're expecting right the we somebody
wrote a virus that's going to infect your computer and what they're
going to do is make your notepad open up a link to child as a
prank or
just as a prank. I don't know what the goal is there. >> We
can tell.
Listen, you're type you're talking to the guy who got his Discord
hacked like [__] two times. Um, I can't believe like
I have a degree in IT security and then >> everything.
You serve all purpose. >> But actually, >> to treat
yourself now,
I don't on my PC. I didn't download like this account as possession
if it's a link in a text document that is now
>> It's not on my PC. I didn't download anything. Uh, >> it
could. I don't know what the laws are in Texas. I do believe
that link is super sus. I don't know if that link will get him
charged criminally.
But that link is certainly enough for like the court of public
opinion to convict him.
Probably all he cares about.
>> No. Yeah, there's nothing on my PC, man.
>> Wait, what? You think Lucari could explain how mutual
TLS works? No,
bro. I can barely explain how mutual TLS works. And I was like
a network engineer who had to like on the fly without having
look it looked it up.
He's a degree in IT security,
bro. I worked as a network engineer. If you wanted me to diagram
MTLS for you, like the handoff and how it works
Like I know the I know the things.
I can say Diffy Helman, but I like I don't know. So I doubt he
knows. He's been streaming longer than I have. >> My game
folder, bro. I really like him. Okay. Like I'm not I'm not dropping
that. I'm sorry.
It's like all I go into. Let's be honest
Okay. Malware bites.
No, I know that it's two-way encryption. I know it's mutual TLS.
I know. >> Maybe later.
Do I need the uh text files aren't viruses? Okay. >> Okay.
Okay. >> Continue with free. Can I start my scan? >> Dude,
why why is he doing this live? I just Bro, you you're like actually
going and knocking down your own excuses live, right? You're
sitting here and you're just like knocking down every excuse
you could possibly have live while giving no plausible explanation
for why you're
It's so dumb. He downloads malware bites. He's going to scan.
What are you going to do if this comes up with nothing? You look
even more guilty. You're just actually Bro, this is like performance
art. He's like finding all of the ways he can [__]
himself over completely amazing. Yeah, you said you downloaded
and deleted it. You already gave the excuse that he went to a
website, it auto downloaded, and then he deleted it after seeing
it. So the virus excuse doesn't even make sense anymore. This
is like a secondary excuse that makes no sense at all. >> Anti
games might be detected as a virus. You might make it worse.
Man, it seems fine so far. Call next. >> I do want to see
the Techone. I do want to see the Techone response. I don't think
it'll happen. I think there's no way Teone doesn't throw him
under the bus, but I think there's a tiny chance Teone decides
to defend him, which would be very funny.
Just the tiniest chance. Is the Charlie video you're linking?
No, it's something else. I don't know what the [__]
this
It's the song. Okay, I see. I see. >> Yo, are you good?
>> Oh, who this? >> Uh, I don't know.
I think so.
Cuz I literally woke up 20 minutes ago
and I just see your chat going crazy.
I don't need details. I just need to know, are you good?
>> I don't know. Don't tell me about any of your chop.
Just tell me. Are you going to kill yourself? Do I have to call
somebody? That's it. >> Is that train? I don't think so.
>> What are you trying to do now? >> No, I don't
think it's train. >> Scan by PC. I don't have any threats.
Virus free. Zero detections. Guess I
>> Why did he do it? Why did he delete it >> Why
did he do it? Why did he do it? Why did he do it?
>> He did it to himself.
said you downloaded and deleted it. I guess I didn't. I thought
I did.
>> Did you like try to download some
some like ROM or something that had a virus on it? Cuz that happened
to you >> Yeah. I mean, but I guess there was no
Brother, brother,
>> brother man.
>> You need notepad for notepad virus. Well, I don't Well,
like the guy chat chat said, I don't think there's like a notepad
like virus thing.
Uh, a virus can can hide in anything these days.
>> but usually viruses have to be like
they can kind of like remain dormant until you activate it by
doing
>> Does that make sense?
>> So, it's really no way to know
until
you have like a full deep scan. >> Try a full deep scan.
But if you if you >> you're you're just going to have to
explain this when you get offline mine. >> Oh god. Oh god.
>> Bro, Charlie video after 1 hour has 250,000 views. Charlie's
video has 250,000 views in an hour. Lucari's done. It's It's
never been more over for
I'll be honest. I thought I truly thought he could get out of
this within the within the first 15 minutes. I was like, "Yeah,
he's getting out of this. There's no problem." He go offline,
you figure out an explanation,
>> and he just streamed through it and knocked down every
possible ally he or sorry, alibi he could have until there was
nothing left. And I don't know how he gets saved at this point.
>> Private Huff, thank you very much for the gifted sub
to Dr. Pib over on kick. Appreciate it, man. >> Dude, he
knocked down every pl every piece of plausible deniability he
could have. He knocked them all down. >> What does he do
now? It's over.
Explain
when I get offline.
>> What do I explain?
>> Okay. What happened?
>> Okay, hold on. Before he gives another explanation,
I got to highlight this message. One second.
>> Damn. And just like that, Stale 2016's 15 minutes of
fame are gone. Unless,
listen, Stale already has the phenotype. Stale, go live stream.
Leak something even more incendiary. You can keep it going, Stale.
Just do it as a joke. As like a troll. You're trolling, Stale.
Just go live and leak some as a troll. All right, keep January
2026. Keep the magic going, Stale. I believe in you. You can
go live. You can save Lucari. You can save Turkey Tom. You can
take the hit for everybody. Okay. Oh, do not let LSF destroy
the life of one black man who raised himself and his family up
out of poverty. Okay? Out of poverty. He raised his family up.
Do not let LSF destroy the life of this poor black man. Okay,
Stale,
you got to step in front of this. You got to take the bullet.
Okay, you got to do it. I believe in you. It's
>> Okay,
so like I said before,
you're going to have to explain and go offline
or if you think you got it, then I'll just leave it at that.
>> This guy's trying to help so gently. Okay. Trying to
be so gentle with this guy right now. >> You're bad at
lying. >> Is that what they say? 9,000y old
>> IS THAT IT? HUH? >> I mean, pretty much the TLDDR
is like I downloaded some nicks.
Those that TXT got on my PC. The name of the TXT didn't look
bad, but then the [__] inside the TX is really bad.
So then I deleted it, but it apparently didn't delete it. And
now I'm [__]
>> Okay. So you open the .exe? >> No, it was an it
was it was a text
>> Oh, a text document. Oh, then you're not
>> It's not that bad. Did you click the
>> Yeah, I checked the link and then I saw it was like
bad and I deleted the the TXT. I'm sorry. He I don't want the
to get away, but like
a little bit in my head I'm just like, could you stop shooting
yourself in the foot in the face? Actually, repeatedly. Could
you just Could you just chill? Could you just chill? The name
didn't look bad. I mean, it was like family couples or something.
It was like what? Teen couples. What the [__] was
it? It was something like that. It was not as bad as you'd think.
Okay. Jesus. Did you see we have another Turkey tom dock? I did
not.
>> Um, link it to me. >> Where did the link take
you? >> Link it to me. 20 The 2026
generational run continues. The January 2026 generational run
continues. Apparently a New Turkey document like a
it was like a uh like it had like it was like uh
what's it called? >> Was it a website? Was it an application?
Was it another notepad? What was it? >> It it was a website
but it was like a cloud thing. >> Like a place where you
would download a
>> Did the file actually start downloading? >> I
didn't didn't download anything. I closed it when I saw the >> Did
it start downloading? Like what do you mean? Like start like
start downloading on its own. >> Like if you download a
video game, it's a pack of files. So like even if you stop the
download at 10% 10% of those files are still on your computer.
So did you start downloading the when you click the link or
did you just close it? >> No, I just closed it. >> Then
you're fine.
>> You know, correct me if I'm wrong. This guy does not
sound like a lawyer. I would not take his advice for it, Lucari.
I would not take his advice at >> H maybe we shouldn't
talk about this. Honestly, chat's making me nervous.
>> Hold on. He stopped to read this chat message.
Atlari, you need to go offline. This is NOT A DISC. STOP TALKING.
THIS IS NOT A GAME.
H maybe we shouldn't talk about this. Honestly, chat's making
me nervous. >> That's why I said you talk to me when you
go offline so we can actually like go through. >> This
guy is a This guy's a ride or die right here. I don't know who
this guy is, but he's like, "Listen, man.
Let's talk offline. Let's talk where you're not being recorded.
Let's talk where you could tell me some that we don't put on
the internet that everybody will see forever that will be brought
up at your trial. Why don't we talk offline?"
>> T, as long as you didn't download anything, you're fine.
People seriously thinking
FBI will party bananers for seeing a link. >> Yeah, it's
not >> I don't know how this works, bro. I I this has never
happened to me before, so I like literally don't know. >> Like
it it's literally just if you downloaded if you downloaded it,
depending on what was downloaded,
you might have to like scan that. But if you didn't initiate
a download, then there's no problem. People are just
>> Yeah, I didn't. >> Did you delete the other files
that you had like the notepad and all that stuff? >> Yeah,
it's all gone now. >> Then it's not that big of a deal.
No, I don't want that [__] My I don't want that [__]
bro.
For real.
>> For real. I guess we're supposed to forget the part
where he's like, I should just delete my hard drive. It's not
worth it. After reading the Texas
Oh boy.
>> Like, viruses aren't really that scary.
>> I don't even know if it was a virus now.
>> do you reckon a Twitch employee was watching this going,
"We can't ban him yet. He keeps self-inccriminating. Probably
not cuz they didn't ban him for like hours after this. But that
would be funny. It's like, yeah, we should ban him. But he does
keep digging the hole further. Like he is further incriminating
himself. Hold. Hold. Don't ban yet. Hold. Don't ban yet. Hold.
Hold. Let him keep doing this. Let him keep cooking,
>> Here. I'm pulling this back just a little bit. I talked
over it.
Like viruses aren't really that scary.
>> I don't even know if it was a virus now.
>> I might have thought I deleted it, deleted something
else and didn't actually delete it and it was just there. Like
it happens. I have a like I have an insane amount of [__]
on my PC. >> Yeah. No hair. >> That's not the problem.
>> What do you mean? >> I mean that's what someone
just told me. >> Oh, I see. I'm not going to I'm not going
to ask for any more details until you go offline
>> in case there is another problem that's actually worth
all this panic. >> Where did I get the link from? I don't
even know.
>> Dude, this guy is a ride or die for real. This guy's
literally sitting here like, I'm literally not going to ask you
more questions that would make you further self-inccriminate
until you're offline. Like, I want I want to ask you questions,
but I'm not going to do that to you. I'm not going to put that
on the That's a ride or die right there. Okay, that's a true
friend. Listen, you might be a but this one time I I will help.
I'll help you get out of this. >> I literally don't even
[__] know, bro. I'm going to be honest.
>> You ever surf like a site in like
>> Okay, you actually I haven't I haven't >> the
places he just goes totally normally. You know when you're like
gooning to like a site and No, no, no.
I
>> you got to know your audience when you ask that question.
>> You know when you're like totally out to a site.
>> Has has this happened to anyone though? Has it happened
to anyone in chat? Has anyone ever serite or site any
>> now? He's going to find his people. Okay. In his chat,
he's going to find his people. click a link and then like
20 things open
and then you close them and they just keep opening.
Has that ever happened to you guys? That's literally what happened
to me. >> I swear to God, >> Lucari. So then I that
raised another
>> What were you doing?
Don't ask that
>> Don't ask that question. Just
>> wait. What sites were you looking? Wait, no. Don't ask.
DON'T ANSWER THAT. >> YOU GUYS KNOW I don't have ad block.
I don't have [__] ad block.
>> I need to get it.
>> You need to get ad block in 2026. You don't have ad
block,
>> brother. Adblock's being phased out. You missed the
decade and a half of ad
>> Why? Because I'm a
>> That's why. Oh,
>> you know what, Lucari? 2026. This is your year to to
really like
I'm going to apparently I'm going to get [__] I'M
GOING TO DROP THE SOFA AND GET IN 2026. THAT'S THE ONLY THING
THAT'S happening in 2026.
I'm getting in my ass. No l no viewers day. Variety's over. This
is it. You can't get any worse than this.
>> Oh, that's where you're wrong. It can get a lot worse
than this. >> It's over.
>> that almost looked like, you know, that almost looked
like he'd stopped coping for a second. Then he went, "Can't get
any worse than this."
Bro, this is at like 700 a.m. Eastern time, by the way. Most
of the continental US was not awake and on their way to work
yet. Most people were not awake and looking at content yet. And
he's like, "You can't get any worse than this." Oh, yeah. I can.
I don't know if you guys saw the blastoff tweet, the the tweet
I usually do to advertise the stream. I've never had more views
on a blastoff tweet ever. And this doesn't even have that much
traction. I didn't get people to retweet. I didn't keep going
and saying, you know, like the blastoff tweet, retweet that.
I didn't do that this time. It's got 4,600 views just naturally
from people searching Lucari on Twitter. People looking for what's
happening with Lucari. I had 30 live viewers at the same time
on this stream. I've never had like more than like 15 live viewers
anytime on Twitter. I for like significant like an hour. I had
30 live viewers on Twitter. I never have live viewers on Twitter.
people just go to Twitch for kick. But today, people were actually
watching on Twitter to see what's going on. And yeah, we did
look at the CCo link. Yep, we did. We did indeed. We watched
this whole video she linked. Okay. Where she's like, I I was
worried Lucari might be a So, I investigated his and I found
it to just be stuff. Okay. He was just under stuff. It wasn't
little kids.
>> Excellent defense. Hear from your tweet. Let's [__]
you.
>> Wow. It's so bad. I'm playing League of Legends. It's
so crazy, >> dude. I can't play League. I play League of
Canada has like a gun to my head right now.
Like, they actually have a gun to my head, bro. There's nothing
I can do. They'll kill me. >> Well, as long as we're deleting
viruses, you might as well go ahead and uninstall
you know, get the full.
>> True. Let's not pretend that League is totally without
blame here. that League isn't itself a gateway drug to being
a Okay, let's not pretend that League itself is not a gateway
drug to being a It obviously is. Play Dota if you don't want
to be a If you want to be a League, >> but it was >> There
you go. We found it. >> DID IT CHAT? IT WAS [__]
Vanguard.
>> Riot Vanguard. >> I don't [__] know.
>> You got to get rid of it.
>> Revol definitely get a lawyer. Oh, I guess I can call
for a lawyer >> for what? >> Well, they're saying
they're scaring me. They say I need a lawyer. >> Okay,
JBT video files. >> You know what's going to happen? >> If
you go out and get a lawyer virus
>> on the family computer lack,
>> that automatically makes you look
>> So, just chill out.
>> Got to call lady boy Mindset. I'm hearing there's Lady
Boy Mindset on the docket later tonight that apparently Asmin
Gold's getting sued. He did a video on it. We might check it
out.
>> Like literally just chill out. >> Lakari is setting
himself up for future
>> You have seen when they get excited when they start
all I know from what I gathered today. >> That's exactly
you click the link behaved within a notepad. It opened a cloud
and it was downloading files, but you said you closed it before
it downloaded. That's it. Don't know what the file you need a
lawyer. If nothing happened, you don't need a lawyer. Okay, then
I don't need a lawyer. I didn't do Well, thing is chat is making
me feel like I did something even though like literally was something
I didn't want to do because it was
put there and I didn't even want it there. So, I don't know.
Oh, Lucari.
It's so funny. Yeah, this is one of the This is one of the only
times you are actively paying attention to your chat. >> I
pay attention to my chat. I like them. >> Yeah, but you're
actually like listening to what they're saying instead of saying
they're This is one of the moments where you should be calling
the
because they're just blowing up your chat being
I think his chat telling him get offline and find a lawyer. Those
people are smart. What's the worst case scenario? You did nothing
wrong. You get offline, you find a lawyer, they tell you you
did nothing wrong, you go back to streaming the next day. What's
What's the problem?
There's only upside there. There's no
>> Really? The the one time?
>> Well, it's kind of a serious situation,
so I'm trusting them.
From what I've heard, it's not that serious. But again, I don't
have all the details,
but from what I'm hearing right now, it's not that serious. >> Are
you sure?
>> No, he's not. Obviously not. >> Me to be like
very serious. >> That's not the problem. Go offline and
ask the details.
Stop joking around and go offline. You are feeding LSF frogs
making things
>> Dude, you okay? >> Like here's the thing. You
go offline and then people LSF LIKE IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOU
DO. YOU GO YOU STAY ONLINE people are like you YOU'RE ONLINE
I GO OFFLINE H SEE HE WENT OFFLINE HE'S GUILTY THIS GUY HE HAS
TO like it doesn't matter what you do they're going to create
a narrative off of everything there's no escape from it bro
>> Lucari it's the internet that's what
you can't go back and change what happened
you got to deal with it as it >> they're still saying get
a lawyer
Okay. Like,
>> can you tell me how to watch the unlisted vaude? I want
to see the his meltdown later. Um, I can't. I This is something
I, you know, my community made for me. I can't give it away.
Okay. You can go and watch previously in this spot if you like,
but that's all the That's all the product I got for you, man.
Sorry, man. This is a whole operation we got going on here. Lucari,
you're not allowed within 500 ft of a school, playground, zoo,
farm, or pet store. Seems appropriate. You literally have to
deal with it as you go as you go along. Once it's out there on
the internet, it's out there. You got to just accept it for what
it is. >> I don't I have to deal with this for the rest
of my life.
just like >> you take a break. >> What is is what
is Lari even mad about? He gets called all the time. This is
like no different than the status quo for him. It's just the
Twitch ban. It's literally only the legal stuff that he has to
deal with. Right. Again, I hate to go back to the same picture.
This is something he's totally comfortable talking about. Not
the content on stream. He's just watching this video with these
two girls in the in the foreground here. >> Doesn't even
phase him. >> It's like who he is.
>> Why is Lucari pretending he he cares about being getting
called a he doesn't he doesn't care at all about being about
getting called a he doesn't give a >> And you're like >> that's
every day for him. >> Mix or any reasonable person.
>> So all he has to worry about is the legal stuff. Everybody
in his audience already kind of assumed that's where he was going
with. Okay, nobody cares in his audience.
figure out what's actually going on. >> Stop feeding into
your LSF chat basically cuz you have 8,000 people here >> Oh,
we hit 8,000. Jesus. >> I just want to play I play AI now.
I just want to play AI files. >> Wake up. I I honestly
Yeah, Ryan, I honestly underplayed the news when it first came
out because I'm like, "Wait, are you shocked?" People were like
pulling it up. I'm like, "Wait, did you not know Lucari's a wait,
did you not know that?" THAT'S THAT WAS MY REACTION when people
were like, "Bring it to me." They're like, "Oh my god, this is
such a big deal." I'm like, "No, I already knew Lucari was a
what are you talking about?" He made it way worse with his reaction.
But when it first broke, I was like, "Dude, this guy literally
openly talks about wanting to like wife up a 10-year-old, a 10-year-old
anime girl, right? He wants that as a waifu. like he openly is
a lollycon.
I'm sorry. This is not that far away from it in my opinion. >> The
FOB is giving me advice. >> All right, we got nine minutes
left on this and then we're going to go to reactions from around
the streamer universe. Okay, we've got Moist Critical, we've
got Asmin Gold, we've got Sodapoppin, we've got SA, we've got
everybody, okay, we've got all the reactions. Uh if you have
other reactions, discord.gg/jstlk,
hop in, throw it in the stream chat, throw in one of the channels,
okay? Stream chat content links. We're looking for all the reactions.
any big streamer reaction. All right,
looking for all of it. Let's check it out. He is just, you know,
sitting here silently now watching his chat. Don't do this to
me. I got to do it to you, Nikur. I'm sorry. This is my job.
I got to do it. I got to play all this [__] >> No,
sering
me saying the someone's message saying the hand was gone, but
there [__] Oh my
>> All right, there's an Asold reaction. We will be checking
that out as well. Did he publish the Asmin Gold TV yet is the
question. Can I get the YouTube video or do I have to find it
in his bod?
>> Someone sent me an LSF link.
>> Came from your Twitter stream. Let's go. The Twitter
streams do work. Love to see >> Maybe I should go offline.
>> So why are you still sitting here,
>> I don't know. Chat makes me feel safe kind of. >> That's
sweet. >> They shouldn't. >> We get a bunch of like
car spams. >> They're not going to do that. >> Are
you sure? >> Yeah, they're going to [__]
>> They're not going to I mean, there's a couple hearts.
I appreciate it, >> dude. Maybe I actually have to go offline
and do a video, man. Explain
>> Oh my, >> dude. I think I have to now.
>> That could have worked bad, bro.
>> Oh god.
>> Everything up until he runs malware bites and finds
nothing. I feel like that could have worked when it becomes clear
he's just coping in every possible
>> Everything before that could have worked. Could have
made it work, man. >> I didn't do anything wrong. I like
honest to God didn't [__] do anything wrong, bro.
I swear I didn't look at that [__] I really didn't
do anything
>> Why was it? >> Why was it? >> What did Vatican
say? Just get a twoe
>> Dude, is that the real Vatican? >> And everything
will be back to normal. >> DUDE, THAT'S WHAT EVERYONE WHO'S
guilty
>> That's not
>> Do you think this ban will be extended before the week's
up if he doesn't make a statement?
Yeah. On Twitch? I think so. I think so. There's just nobody
deals with nobody will deal in nuance. You have to fix it yourself.
If you're accused of being a you have to fix it yourself. Nobody
will give you the benefit of the doubt. Nobody will give you
nuance. You have to come out and prove that it's not correct.
Right? If you're credibly accused at some point, like Lucari
kind of is here. He has to go and say something. Twitchban is
somewhere between one day and two weeks. Stazzy. We don't know
if it's a week yet. I think some people are saying it's a week
now, but um I haven't seen the tweet saying it's a week. I've
seen between one day and TWO WEEKS. >> LIKE, OH MY GOD,
NO. I UP. OH, THEY RELEASED a video. They're like, I'm going
on a break, guys. I'll come back a better person. They [__]
come back two weeks later like nothing happened. >> Holy
[__] Got pinged so much in your server. Wait a minute.
I got to check
>> maybe I talk to my Discord.
>> That's not Discord what I do.
>> Don't do that.
Okay, I'm incis.
>> Those guys all want to watch you fall right now. They
just they're bored. Okay, they'll watch you totally blow your
life up. Don't ask those people what to do. >> Discord
now. So, if people are in your Discord that are trying to inform
me of stuff, people are telling me
I need to know stuff. What's going on?
>> I don't know who this is in the call with him right
now. >> WHAT'S EVERYONE JUST SAYING me
>> Oh man, I just found the next clip I'm going to once
this ends. I got it. I got it right now. >> Okay, let's
see what the going on here. >> We're so close to the end.
Five minutes, guys. T-minus is 5 minutes and we're we're on to
the next thing. People reacting to this. This is where he goes
offline. This is before everybody really has started reacting.
>> Yo, why are you getting so many people joining your
Discord now? What the hell? >> Oh, great. You didn't spend
money on it? I mean, I legit can't prove that. >> Dude,
the spending money thing is such a crazy code. >> Just
end the stream.
It's been like actually talk about what's going on. Economy situation
is
>> Chad, my bad. I promise we'll we'll be back playing
variety tomorrow.
>> That was almost the title, but it was worse. This this
Twitch streamer situation is disgusting. He didn't even get crazy
from Charlie. He got
Oh boy.
It wasn't He didn't He got upgraded from crazy to disgusting.
Man, that is That's rough. Holy [__] dude. >> Putting
this guy down right now.
>> I just got jump scared by Charlie, dude. What the >> last
is not last rank, dude. >> Fine.
Be all right. I didn't do anything >> People will dig up
your old old streams, so be careful. It's okay. I mean, they
can look at my old streams. There's nothing streams. >> Dude,
what did that say? People will dig up your old streams, so be
careful. A lot of LSF threads will pop up in the next hours.
Be ready for that. Literally half of the people in here are LSF
frogs blowing it out of proportion.
Gura. That's got to be a fake Gura. But that's it's it is funny
because that is the next clip I'm going to. Okay, the next clip
I'm going to is in fact from LSF and it is in fact apparently
let's let's read the titles. A quick preview before we finish
the VOD. Lucari's friend and known NYC stream sniper Lord talks
about his illegal file sharing history and says that Lucari was
his first quote unquote customer.
>> So, be careful. It's okay. I mean, they can look at
my old streams. There's nothing bad.
>> That's not true. >> But yeah, um,
>> thanks for watching, guys. I appreciate it. Viewers
day. I'll still try to make viewers day happen. All right. I
know you guys are going crazy right now. I'll try to make my
old streams if you're >> There's nothing bad, guys. Take
a look at my old streams. There's nothing bad. >> Should
I just end stream? I probably shouldn't host anyone, huh?
>> Wait, you could No, don't take LOL subs into anybody's
chat. I could hold [__] on my life. >> Don't
do that. Don't do that.
>> [__] You guys want to go watch Jenna? >> Don't
Don't do Don't do that. Don't
>> you watch the >> Wait, hold on. I just saw a guy
with the
You guys watch?
>> Don't Don't do Don't do that.
>> This What was this right here? >> Oh, I lied.
Not Not the name I thought it was. >> My friend. I like
him. >> You know what? How would you rate Ghost? Cuz he's
been kind of cooking on Where's Meat? Why don't you give him
9,000? >> Is he live right now?
>> Should we raid ghost electricity? >> Yeah. Go
ahead. Just dump all these LSFers on the ghost and see how he
reacts to that. >> Uh, I guess I could. >> No, don't
do that. Like, what's going to
>> Whoever you take this chat to, they're going to keep
spamming the same things. And you don't don't just just get rid
of it. Just end the stream. >> Dude, who cares? >> What
do you, >> bro? Who cares? Dude, if I was going to get
a raid of a bunch of LSF people, I would love that.
Who cares, man? You guys want to watch? >> Why are you
guys watch? We know can handle them, >> Oh my. >> He
can handle them, I think. Right. >> Jesus Christ.
>> Jenna would know what to do. We'll write >> Why
would you bring this stuff to another streamer to talk about?
>> You're literally doing the thing that you were afraid
was going to happen. >> Like, what is wrong with you? Okay,
>> we're
I won't I won't I'm >> truly truly >> GG shot.
>> I'll see you guys next time. Thanks for >> You
could troll and down to like to like a one one Andy if you want.
Oh, I would be real.
>> Anybody whose name was mentioned positively by Lucari
is not appreciating that in this stream. Okay, Lucari was throwing
out names like relationships and stuff. He's like, "Oh, something
about Sand and Sans's Wi-Fi, something about Asmin Gold." Right?
He was just throwing out names of other big streamers, trying
to go like, "Guys, people like me. Guys, people like me." He
was trying to get like a, you know, some amount of social proof
from them. And I guarantee you every streamer who he went to
to name, they're going to come out and go like, "No, no, I don't
know the car." No. [__] that. [__] that.
No. No. >> Yes. I feel >> going to totally >> I
should help a small streamer.
>> I honest to God feel like I should help a small streamer.
Let me see.
>> Oh, here. Type for rage. Just >> I'm joking. I'm
joking. Don't actually do that. Don't Don't actually do that.
Don't actually do that. >> His ex-girlfriend already felt
at him. Uh, yeah, she did do that. >> That's his own fault,
though. >> Figure it out.
>> If you listen to her voice, you start to understand
why it might have actually worked for him. Okay, let me just
click on this this video she posted as a part of her post. Let's
read this real quick, actually, before we move on to everything
else. Just in case you missed it earlier, Kuko actually, you
know, she kind of put him down today. All right. Lucari and I
broke up. Over a year and a half ago when we dated, I had asked
to see his folder because I heard allegations. I did my due diligence.
I like how she says, "I did my due diligence." Like she didn't
just straight up like
off with him. I did my due diligence. No, you were just horny.
I did my due diligence when I suspected something was a miss.
No, you didn't. You just wanted to like goon. I I Bro, it's We'll
listen to the VA and you make you be the judge. Okay. Was she
really suspicious of like stuff or something crazy? Or was she
just like, "Oh,
hot. Let's go." When I couldn't find anything crazy, I stopped
suspecting. Clearly, I was wrong. And she links this video. The
worst I saw was NTR. This is like, okay, but I don't know. But
now I know he could have hid the worst of it. I don't know why
people keep associating me with him when he has a new girlfriend
and I'm getting rage baited into a response. So, here it is.
Now, I just want you
to listen to me, okay? Sorry, not listen to me. I want you to
listen to her voice and try to imagine why Lukari a known somebody
who's now exposed himself as as a guy who's looking at looking
at looking at I >> based on his based on her voice. Sorry.
Based on her voice, why would he
date
>> Yo, what up? So, you want to tell Chad about our bonding
moment yesterday? >> Is it okay? >> Yeah, sure. You
can tell. >> I'll do anything for her. >> You're
You're not going to hold back on what I'm going to say, right?
you on to the right path.
>> Whoa, slow down. >> Ends here. >> How much
are you going to tell them?
>> Found you. >> You're going to tell my chat everything?
>> You're going to tell my chat everything.
>> Now, if you had to guess, if you just heard the voice
and you had to guess, does the voice go to >> You're going
to tell my chat everything?
>> Can you handle Okay, long story short in this one, she
finds no lollycon. She finds like a bunch of and then they watch
the together.
That's the that's the long and short of this one. Okay. Okay.
So, we're going to watch this this clip first. Lucari's friend
and known NYC stream sniper Lord talks about his illegal file
sharing history and says that Lucari was his first customer.
What is this? >> Oh, you are.
>> Was that your stream name? >> No, that's my that
is my original stream name.
But then Twitch's like, "Nope.
>> Why are you headed?"
>> That's a old lore to it.
So back in the days when there was no such thing as
>> Oh, this guy was doing Star Trek Fleet Command. We did
that sponsor. Let's go. >> Like YouTube. >> Let's
go. >> You just used to watch Henry. >> No. So we
used to have a a website where you could download animes.
Remember those days? that you have to download >> using
uh it's like illegal. >> Yeah. Yeah. You have to download
illegal anime just to watch. >> What is it called again?
Bit Torrent.
>> Torrent.
See, I know I'm old.
>> people are >> my This guy This guy has like the
most insane. What is the spinal alignment here? His like back
is going back this way and his neck is like all the way forward
here. >> Business. If you're a freak, >> there's
always a bigger freak. >> Oh, yeah. >> Are you a
freak?
>> Used to.
>> Are you a gooner? >> I I tell you like I used
to distribute
[__] I tried to cut it but
so I was getting a lot of money because of that. People was downloading
my videos on Mega Upload. I don't know if you heard that website.
>> I do.
>> So, I was big on mega upload.
>> I still
call me the There you go.
>> You were there.
>> You gave the people what they wanted. >> Yep.
And you know who's my f my first >> Who? Who? >> He's
a streamer, too. >> Oh my god. Leak
>> might know him. Well, people mid chat might know him.
>> Lucari. Know who Lari is?
>> There you go. >> Oh my god. He is your first customer.
>> Let's go. EDP445.
Absolutely massive day for him today. He is now the second most
famous black on the internet. Okay.
EDP has been waiting for so long. Black people there's they have
such a clean history in this regard. Okay. Had EDP's been waiting
and waiting and waiting. And now is finally his day where he
is not the most popular black on the
We don't count Michael Jackson. He was white at the end. Okay.
R. Kelly. God damn it. Don't streamer streamer content creator
influencer. God damn it. >> Stop trying to counteract.
>> Are you allowed to leak that?
>> Be friends for long.
>> Oh my god. That is crazy. The lore is deep.
Ah, so did you guys stream together on Justin TV? >> No,
I was streaming >> Thanks Water Jar
>> at that time. So I was I was part of his
>> How did these two end up streaming together at this
point? Why is this like random Asian girl in a car with this
guy driving around >> online? Hold on. Where is this?
>> Hold on. What is this? Oh, they played Terara. That
was a total Bro, do we have to look at the Do we have to look
at the like little girl race in Terara? Did he just say they
were playing terror together? Uh >> oh. Korean Korean MMO
fans about to get blown the >> No, I was streaming. He
wasn't
at that time. So I was I was part of his guilt on a game called
Terra Online.
>> The guilt name was Men Up. >> And that was his
second command.
He was the leader.
>> Wow. And how did he know that you were
>> Cuz I was giving all the links. Wait, how did you get
the >> I just downloaded from Torrance and then I got some
people who translate in English
and I'm just uploading. >> Wait, why can't they just get
it from Torrent? They're lazy. >> They're lazy,
>> I was doing all the hard work. >> If you have
needs, you'll always find a way. But I guess they were just not
>> they they didn't want it enough.
>> Parent Line was an asset flip of Guild Wars 2. I don't
think so. They paid you. How much do you pay for that? >> So
for one link if you click it and you download it's like two cents.
>> But I get millions and millions of downloads from different
people.
>> Two cents and you were making money off of it which
means that there are that many people who like >> Yep.
There you go.
>> This blows my mind. What the f? What's wrong with you
people? Hey man, back then there was no internet. Well, there
was internet, but it was no live stream like live videos. >> Oh
my god.
>> Yeah, you are smart. You're like the the the smuggler.
>> Yep. That was those times.
>> Yeah, he was like tra He was the trafficker. Really?
When you think about >> I can get off here. >> You
can? >> Yeah. Oh, yeah. Cuz he's >> My god. Okay,
so that's funny. Also a little suspicious. Let's check out the
soda popping reaction. All right, this is the one of the first
ones we're looking at.
>> This is the soda popping reaction. 3 minutes 15 second
reaction. Good for you, guys. >> Uh yeah, I woke up just
a couple Reddit threads. Vicki was like, "Hey, have you seen
LSF?" I'm like, "No, what's going on?" Lucari,
what did Lucari do?
I was like, "Oh man, top LSF post. Ooh, this looks awful." And
then I scroll down. I'm like, "Another one. Wait, another one.
How much content did this guy put out while being like outed
as
potentially a I mean >> a lot he the answer is a lot like
hours and hours and hours and hours >> it it's looking
like or at least
the notepad
and it's just scrolling scrolling and the thing is he streamed
the whole thing he actually dug he dug a hole straight down to
like China
town actually just kept digging. Crazy.
Yeah, crazy stuff.
He kept >> He really did. >> Yeah. I don't know,
>> bro. It's like, dude, the super cut of that stream is
going to go so insane, right? Like, as he goes through the different
excuses, you start with like the list of plausible excuses you
could have and he like meticulously crosses every single one
off of the list. So, the only thing you could be left with is
assuming that he's an actual
like that was an actual that was actual cinema. Like you couldn't
write it any better than that. He just slowly goes through every
possible excuse he could have and he slowly cancels them all
out for himself.
Amazing. >> What he was thinking? Um I mean best thing
is to just you know don't have a notepad of
uh like child or teenager. I don't I don't know. I mean even
then and then like
thousands of links. I didn't look too deep into it, but I mean,
it didn't take long for me to realize
uh can't be talking with this person no more. This is not good.
So, o that's about where that's at.
>> thought about messaging him being like, "Dude, uh you
again 20 foot pole, 30 500 foot pole distance, dude.
Can't even be like, "Hey, it was cool knowing you. You were cool
when I didn't think you were." Nope. Just pure distance, guys.
We got to get the out of >> I'm sorry, bro. >> Shouldn't
have done that.
>> And worst of all,
>> worst of all, >> at least not on stream, dude.
He
>> Oh, hold on. >> He streamed. Yeah,
>> the big dagger's coming.
>> I almost Do I even want to go to the VOD? I'm not going
to do it on stream obviously, but do like me in my own free time.
I don't know if I could bring
>> to watch that VOD without intense secondhand embarrassment.
>> Like intense. I don't think I could bring myself to
do it. >> Or if you're like a drama streamer, just like
glee. Just like pure glee. Like this guy is actually self- emilating
for no reason and I get to make money off of
Dude, hold on. Uh, every drama streamer POV. Okay. Every drama
streamer POV.
>> Oh, hold on. I need to play it again. >> Losing
his mind. And I'm reaping all the
>> Dude, every time. Okay, that's just it. I'm reaping
all the benefits. All the benefits. Close this. Close this. We're
still on soda popping. Let's get back to soda popping. >> Really?
He deleted it? I'm sure it's still out there somewhere.
But crazy
>> Russell did already. Oh god.
>> Yeah, I couldn't even watch some of the clips. I watched
most of them just to really get a gist cuz you know this is a
big deal.
>> Not joining Only Fangs
>> in case anyone was wondering. Uh yeah, I don't know.
It's I don't see any recovering from this. Uh, at this point,
if I was in issues, I'd be worried about legitimate legal
issues, right? Where you at a legal real life standpoint, not
just your real life or not your your um internet reputation.
>> Not good.
>> Not good, man. Xbox Live show. Let's just jump right
into the Xbox Live show, guys. Ready to pivot? Did I say enough?
Have I made my stance clear? We good?
Oh, I missed it. I missed it somewhere in here where he says
>> I I just missed it right there. >> Your um internet
reputation.
>> Not good. >> Miss it.
>> Xbox live show >> not joining Only Fangs was the
big thing. Okay, worst of all,
he's not going to be in Only Fangs this season, guys. No Only
Fangs for Lucari. Oh. Oh